welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today we are
discussing happiness
we're going to discuss the science of
happiness because indeed there are
excellent Laboratories that have worked
for many decades to try and understand
what is this thing that we call
happiness and what brings us happiness
in the short and long term
fact we could probably point to
happiness as one of the most sought
after States or Commodities or emotions
whatever you want to call it happiness
is what many people are seeking in work
in relationships and in general and yet
most of us can't really Define exactly
what happiness is or means for us we can
point to certain experiences we can try
and describe our states of mind and body
but most people recognize the feeling
when we have it and we certainly
recognize the feeling of not being happy
whether or not that means simply not
being happy as the absence of happiness
or all-out depression
now one of the key problems in trying to
understand happiness and indeed the
science and psychology of happiness is
that it does indeed involve other
similar things things like joy and
gratitude and meaning and indeed many
scientists and psychologists have argued
for many many decades about what
happiness really is we can come up with
so-called operational definitions of
Happiness operational definitions are
basically agreed upon terms or agreed
upon definitions and conditions that
will define something such as happiness
much in the same way that we can all
probably come up with an operational
definition of milk but of course milk
can be cow's milk it can be oat milk it
can be soy milk etc etc so too Something
like Happiness can be micro divided and
sliced and diced into as many things as
we decide today we are really going to
focus on three main things first we are
going to define happiness as a brain
State and as a state of mind and body
we're going to take a look at what the
science says about all of that second we
are going to talk about tools and
practices for placing ourselves into
states of happiness and while for most
of us we think of Happiness as something
that only arrives through the
acquisition of some goal or some thing
external to us and of course that is
true there is also something called
synthetic happiness or synthesized
happiness which turns out to be at least
as powerful and perhaps even more
powerful I'll just say right off the bat
that I'm not going to tell you that all
you have to do is sit in a chair and
imagine being happy in order to feel
happy synthesize happiness actually
involves some very concrete steps that
have been defined by excellent labs in
Psychology so we're going to talk about
synthesize happiness
as it relates to what you can do to
obtain happy States more readily or more
frequently
and then third we're going to talk about
some of the misconceptions or what I
would call the contradictions of
Happiness research and what I mean by
that is most of you have probably heard
about the general conditions for
obtaining happiness and they always seem
to circle back to some of the same basic
features of get great sleep have great
social connection pursue meaning don't
Focus
to any over extent on things like
pursuing money because there are indeed
these studies that show that the amount
of money that people makes does not
necessarily scale directly with
happiness
we'll talk about those studies in some
detail a little bit later and while all
of that literature is very powerful and
informative there is what I see as a
contradiction which is for instance that
for many of us including myself
especially in the years when I was in
graduate school and a postdoc there were
times in which
pursuing and being involved in work and
pursuing degrees and finding meaning in
my vocation actually separated me from
the opportunity to have quite as many
social connections or quite as much
sleep or quite as much exercise or even
quite as much Sunshine for that matter
so all of the things that we're told
that we need in order to access
happiness on a regular basis oftentimes
contradict with the pressures and the
requirements of not just daily life but
in building a life that allows us to
have the kind of resources that we need
in order to have things like Quality
Social connection
and the time and opportunity to get
regular exercise and great nutrition etc
etc so again while this isn't
necessarily a complaint with any of the
research out of the fields of psychology
on happiness it is important that we
acknowledge these contradictions that
exist in the discussion around happiness
in particular the popular discussions
around the science of Happiness so today
what we are going to arrive at what you
will finish this episode with is a set
of tools and a framework for
understanding the pursuit of happiness
in the short and long term as it relates
to the research from psychology but also
the neuroscience and my goal today is
really to try and place that all into a
structured framework so that you can
know where you are in your journey or
the landscape around happiness in your
Pursuit of Happiness and what I won't
tell you is that you need to abandon all
goals in terms of pursuing
money career Etc and simply focus on
relationships but we will talk about
what constitutes an excellent social
Bond or even an excellent conversation
there's excellent research that points
to the fact that even rather shallow
connections that is connections between
people that you happen to just see in
the hallway on a regular basis not even
requiring close bonds of any kind can be
built into close bonds that can deliver
a tremendous amount of feeling and
genuine social connection provided
certain conditions are met
so today again is really about
understanding the science of Happiness
understanding the mechanisms underlying
what we call happiness and providing you
a framework by which you can pursue and
Achieve happiness not just as a
long-term goal and not just as a
day-to-day goal of little micro
exercises of gratitude Etc but rather as
a way to think about happiness as a
state that you have control over at
least in terms of your ability to access
what I would call the algorithms that
enable us or open the opportunity to
experience happiness now before we begin
today's episode I'd like to talk about a
very specific tool that applies yes to
our pursuit of happiness but actually to
our pursuit of everything including
quality sleep and ongoing motivation Etc
I've talked many many times before on
this podcast and on other podcasts and
on social media about the critical value
of getting regular bright light ideally
sunlight in your eyes within the first
hour of waking or if the sun isn't out
when you wake up in the morning to turn
on a lot of bright artificial lights and
then get sunlight in your eyes for
anywhere from 5 to 20 minutes depending
on how cloudy it is
in the early part of the day absolutely
outsized effects on mood and focus
during the day and quality of sleep at
night
now there's another sort of central
tenet of getting great sleep and
improving mood and focus throughout the
day and that's to avoid bright
artificial light exposure to your eyes
between the hours of about 10 pm to 4
a.m now leaving shift workers aside and
we have an entire episode of Ode to
shift work most people are asleep at
night and awake during the day and you
would be wise to avoid exposure of your
eyes to Bright artificial light between
the hours of 10 pm and 4 AM if you're
going to use screens or artificial
lights dim them down as far as you can
now there are several studies that point
to the fact that one of the major issues
with getting bright light in your eyes
between the hours of 10 pm and 4 AM is
that it has a negative impact on the
so-called dopaminergic or dopamine
circuits of the brain and body which can
enhance depression that is lead to
ongoing lower mood and affect so that's
a reason to dim the lights or avoid
Bright Lights between 10 pm and 4 am
however I and many others need to use
artificial lighting screens sometimes
even between the hours of 10 npm and
midnight or even midnight to 3 A.M
depending on what's going on in my life
or your life that may include you as
well now it turns out that there are
powerful ways to offset some not all but
some of the negative effects of viewing
artificial lights between the hours of
10 pm and 4 AM and one of the most
powerful ways to do that is to Simply
adjust the overall brightness of your
artificial lighting throughout the day
and in the evening so one of the issues
nowadays that we're really facing is
that people are simply not getting
enough bright light in their eyes from
sunlight or from other sources during
the daytime and they're getting far too
much bright light in their eyes
largely from artificial sources of
course in the evening and at night not
just from 10 pm to 4 a.m but also in the
evening hours from 6 to 10 p.m and so on
and so forth so a very simple yet
powerful Solution that's supported by
peer-reviewed research in humans is to
try and make your indoor working and or
home environment during the day as
bright as possible now if you can
achieve that through direct sunlight
terrific if you can get outside a lot
during the daytime terrific but many
people simply cannot but most people do
have some windows in their environment I
realize some don't but most people do
and as a consequence most people are
using rather dim artificial lighting
indoors during the day and then very
bright artificial lighting indoors in
the evening and at night
that's a problem and if you think about
it logically you want to do the exact
reverse so it's been shown that if you
simply increase the amount of bright
artificial light that you are exposed to
during the day
and remember this is not an excuse to
not get your morning sunlight viewing
but in addition to that to make your
indoor artificial lights very bright
bright bright throughout the day and
then much dimmer from the hours of 6 PM
until bedtime or if you can't do that
then maybe as soon as you get home from
about 8 PM until bedtime and then dim
them way way down between 10 pm and 4 AM
are off entirely that's going to be a
far better pattern for your sleep wake
Cycles Focus mood Etc then what most
people do which is to have a few windows
in their indoor working environment
during the day and keep the indoor
lights rather dim at a time when they
need more photons more light energy and
then in the evening when they get home
because it's dark outside they tend to
turn the lights much brighter you
actually want to do the reverse now
there's an even simpler solution which
is to get some bright sunlight in your
eyes right around the time of sunset it
doesn't have to be exactly at Sunset it
could be in the late afternoon and
evening but it's been shown now in
studies on on humans and I'll provide a
link to at least one of those studies
that by getting some bright light in
your eyes ideally from sunlight in the
late afternoon and evening and of course
the timing will vary Depending on time
of year and where you are located on the
planet but facing the sun around sunset
you don't actually have to see The Sun
Cross down below the Horizon but facing
the sun around that time for anywhere
from five to ten minutes or even less
even two to five minutes can adjust the
sensitivity of neurons in your retina
that communicate light information to
the brain and make it such that in the
evening when you use artificial lights
they aren't going to have as much of a
detrimental effect on your dopamine
system and for impairing your sleep okay
so the idea is as much bright light
ideally from sunlight but also from
artificial sources from the time you
wake up in the morning until the evening
maybe around six or seven o'clock maybe
in the summer months a little bit later
and then really try and get as little
bright light in your eyes as you can in
the evening and nighttime hours
and ideally you would also get some
sunlight exposure right around the time
of sunset or in the late afternoon go
outside take your sunglasses off don't
try and do this Through a Windshield or
through a window it will not work you
have to get outside if you're under an
overhang at least try and get some
direct sunlight in your eyes at that
time and that will adjust the
sensitivity of your retina such that
bright artificial lights or artificial
lights of any kind that you're exposed
to in the evening and in the late hours
of the night won't have as much of a
detrimental effect that said if you go
to the bathroom in the middle of the
night try and keep the lights dim many
people have asked whether or not for
instance a night light or a flashlight
is going to have as much of a negative
effect this is very straightforward if
you think about it if you shine a light
at something you can see into your
environment if you've ever been camping
or you've walked with a flashlight you
can see things around you that you
wouldn't otherwise of course but if you
were to shine that light in your eyes it
would be far brighter so yes of course
if you get up in the middle of the night
and you can use your phone flashlight to
illuminate the environment that you're
in in so you can safely go to where you
need to go and then back to bed that's
going to be far better than turning on
the lights or of course shining light in
your eyes right so the idea is bright
bright in the morning and throughout the
day and as dim and dark as possible at
night and that afternoon light viewing
provides sort of what I call a Netflix
inoculation that will allow you to
adjust your retinal sensitivity and give
you a little bit more flexibility in
terms of allowing some nighttime light
exposure without the detrimental effects
now I realize today's episode is about
happiness it's not about sunlight or
dopamine and yet as we'll talk about
more in just a moment if you're not
optimizing your sleep and if you are
using or being exposed to light rather
at the wrong times of the day night
cycle that is going to make it very hard
for the other sorts of practices that
relate to happiness to have their full
impact so the backdrop where I would say
the kind of landscape of your chemicals
and your hormones is powerfully
controlled by not just the brightness of
light but the timing of light and your
exposure to light in particular your
exposure to light to your eyes is
something that you have a lot of control
over you don't have absolute control but
you have a lot of control over and it's
been proven that even these small steps
which are completely cost free they
require just a few minutes of time but
no purchase a product or anything else
can allow you to greatly adjust your
neurochemistry and your hormones in the
direction of better mood better sleep
and happiness before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools for the
general public in keeping with that
theme I'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
thesis thesis makes custom nootropics
and as I've said many times before on
this podcast I am not a fan of the word
nootropics because it means smart drugs
and frankly there are no specific neural
circuits in the brain or body for being
quote unquote smart thesis understands
this and they've developed custom
nootropics that are designed to bring
your brain and body into the state
that's ideal for what you need to
accomplish they use the highest quality
ingredients things like phosphodidal
serine Alpha GPC many ingredients I've
talked about before on this podcast and
that I have going to use myself I've
been using thesis for over a year now
and I can confidently say that their
nootropics have been a game changer for
me I like their nootropic for clarity I
use that before cognitive work often and
I like their nootropic for energy and I
often use that before workouts in
particular workouts that are especially
intense to get your own personalized
nootropic starter kit go online to
takethesis.com huberman take their
three-minute quiz and thesis will send
you four different formulas to try in
your first month again that's
takethesis.com huberman and use the code
Huber minute checkout to get 10 off your
first box today's episode is also
brought To Us by inside tracker inside
tracker is a personalized nutrition
platform that analyzes data from your
blood and DNA to help you better
understand your body and help you meet
your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed with a quality blood test one
of the problems with a lot of blood
tests and DNA tests out there however is
that you get information back about
lipids and levels of hormones and levels
of metabolic factors and so on but you
don't know what to do with that
information inside tracker has a very
easy to use online site where you can
monitor your levels and you can click on
any specific marker any specific hormone
or metabolic factor and it will tell you
the behavioral tools for instance
exercise the nutrition tools and the
supplementation based tools that you can
use in order to bring those numbers into
the appropriate ranges for your
immediate and long-term health goals if
you'd like to try inside tracker you can
visit insidetracker.com huberman to get
20 off any of inside trackers plan again
that's inside tracker.com huberman to
get 20 off today's episode is also
brought To Us by Helix sleep Helix makes
mattresses and pillows that are of the
absolute highest quality I started
sleeping on a helix mattress well over a
year ago and it's been the best sleep
that I've ever had one of the things
that makes Helix mattresses so unique is
that they match the design of the
mattress to your unique sleep needs so
for instance if you go onto their
website you can take a brief quiz it's
only takes about two or three minutes
and you'll answer questions like do you
tend to run hot or cold throughout the
night or whether or not you sleep on
your back your side of your stomach or
maybe you don't know
regardless they will match you to the
custom mattress that's ideal for your
sleep needs for me that was the dusk
dusk mattress which for me was not too
firm not too soft and was ideal for my
sleep patterns
you take the quiz and you'll find out
what mattress is ideal for your sleep
patterns so if you're interested in
upgrading your mattress go to
helixsleep.com huberman take their brief
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress and you'll get up to
200 off any mattress order and two free
pillows they have a 10 year warranty and
you get to try out the mattress for 100
nights risk free again if you're
interested you can go to helixsleep.com
huberman for up to 200 off and two free
pillows let's talk about happiness this
thing that everybody seems to want and
yet not everybody can agree upon what
exactly it is or how to get it
now I want to start by quoting a
previous guest on the huberman Lab
podcast and that is a colleague of mine
at Stanford School of Medicine Dr Carl
diceroth who's both a bioengineer
and a clinician that is he's a
psychiatrist who spends a lot of his
time both running a laboratory and
seeing patients human patients of course
and I once was at a meeting where I
heard Carl say something to the extent
of we don't know what other people feel
in fact most of the time we don't even
really know how we feel and while that
statement was meant to report several
different things about the way that the
brain works and emotions Etc
one of the things that he was
emphasizing and I know he was
emphasizing it because he confirmed this
for me
was the fact that
language
things like the word happiness or Joy or
meaning or pleasure or Delight are
actually not very precise when it comes
to describing our brain and body States
so for instance if I tell you I'm
feeling pretty happy
I know what that means for me at least
in this moment but you don't really know
whether or not it means the same thing
as what pretty happy means for you if I
say I'm extremely happy and I have a big
grin I have a grin on my face that I
can't seem to wipe off my face well then
you might get a sense of how much
happier I am than pretty happy
but it's still hard to calibrate my
level of internal state or happiness and
the same is true for you and for
everybody else and it's important for us
to acknowledge this because at this
point in human history 2022
we don't really have a measurement like
body temperature or heart rate or heart
rate variability or even a way to
measure neurochemicals in the brain and
body that give us anything better than a
crude correlate or an estimate at Best
of What happiness is
so that's really important to understand
and to keep in mind throughout this
episode it doesn't mean that we cannot
have a strong
data-driven conversation about happiness
and what brings us to a state of
happiness but it's very important to
understand that language is not an ideal
and maybe even a deficient tool in terms
of describing our emotions and our
states of Mind and Body now equally
important is to understand that while we
do have neurotransmitters that is the
chemicals that are released between
neurons nerve cells that allow neurons
to communicate things like glutamate and
Gaba for instance and we have what are
called neuromodulators These are
chemicals also released by neurons that
impact the electrical firing and
chemical release of other neurons things
like serotonin and dopamine and
acetylcholine and epinephrine
neuromodulators and neurotransmitters
are always present in a cocktail in our
brain and body that that is they are
present in different ratios and at
different levels so we need to
completely discard with the idea that
any one neurotransmitter or any one
neuromodulator is solely responsible for
a state of happiness or for a lack of
state of happiness for that matter
that said it is true that for people
that tend to have lower Baseline levels
of for instance dopamine
their levels of happiness or we should
say their self-reported levels of
happiness tend to be lower than for
those that have greatly elevated
Baseline levels of dopamine now this can
be best appreciated at the extremes
where for instance in conditions like
Parkinson's disease or other conditions
where people's levels of dopamine in
their brain is severely depleted
mind you we also see this in drug
addicted individuals that are in a
withdrawal State because they're trying
to quit or they don't have access to the
drug that normally stimulates release of
dopamine think the cocaine addict who
can't get cocaine or the methamphetamine
addict that can't was trying to avoid
taking methamphetamine
where the Parkinson's patient who has
fewer dopamine neurons because they
degenerated those individuals do tend to
be more depressed they tend to have
lower affects they are less happy at
least that's how they report themselves
to be emotionally and that's what we
observe when we look at them
behaviorally in terms of the amount of
smiling the amount of energy they seem
to have
at the opposite extreme and while still
focusing on the kind of pathology of
neurotransmitter and neuromodulator
systems an individual who is in a manic
phase of bipolar
will tend to have very elevated levels
of dopamine and those people will talk a
mile a minute and they won't require
sleep and at least to them every idea is
an exciting idea and one that they want
to pursue we did an entire episode about
bipolar depression AKA bipolar disorder
so if you'd like to learn more about
that please check out that episode that
and all other episodes of the podcast of
course you can find at hubermanlab.com
in all formats but the point here is
that very low levels are very high
levels of dopamine are correlated with
certain states of for instance
low happiness or the absence of
Happiness we could even call it
depression in some cases or extreme
happiness or even Euphoria sometimes
even inappropriate Euphoria as is the
case with bipolar
depression or some kind sometimes called
bipolar Mania or bipolar disorder
now of course there's a range in between
depressed and Manic and most people
fortunately reside somewhere in that
range and it is indeed a Continuum and I
think it's safe to say that levels of
dopamine probably do correlate with
levels of happiness but there is no one
single chemical nor chemical signature
that is no specific recipe of you know
two parts dopamine to one part serotonin
to one part acetylcholine that we can
say equates to happiness indeed there's
now tremendous controversy as to whether
or not for instance having lower levels
of Serotonin is actually the cause of
depression or merely correlates with
depression or maybe doesn't even
correlate with depression at all this
became especially controversial because
in the last year so-called serotonin
hypothesis of depression has been called
into question and indeed it does seem to
be the case that for individuals that
are depressed their levels of Serotonin
can sometimes be normal
however and this isn't important however
that does not mean that administering
drugs that increase levels of serotonin
in depressed people does not sometimes
and indeed often help ameliorate some of
their symptoms I should mention that
many of the selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor so-called ssris such as Prozac
and zoloftits Etc are still considered
excellent treatments for conditions like
OCD and so on and so forth but what I'm
trying to do is make two important
points first of all
that language is not a great indicator
of internal State especially when trying
to understand other people's internal
State and that is especially true for
things like happiness and that there is
no one chemical signature of happiness
there's no one neuromodulator or
combinations of neuromodulators that we
can say is the cocktail for happiness
but and it's a very important but
when levels of dopamine and serotonin
tend to be chronically low for an
individual below their typical Baseline
they will yes tend to be lower in affect
and have lower mood and less episodes of
Happiness per day per week per month per
year Etc
conversely when an individual has
elevations in dopamine and serotonin
levels in particular dopamine levels and
the other so-called catecholamines which
include epinephrine and norepinephrine
so the catecholamines are dopamine
epinephrine and norepinephrine they're
all very similar biochemically they all
lead to states of elevated motivation
energy and so on
when those chemicals are elevated above
Baseline people do tend to have elevated
sense of mood and well-being and in
particular sense of possibility about
what they can do in the world and what
the world can offer them so we need to
acknowledge those two features of
language and neurochemistry as we wade
into the discussion about the psychology
of happiness and in particular about the
controlled experiments that have been
done in excellent Laboratories focused
on the psychology of happiness and what
brings happiness and what does not there
have been some excellent studies on
happiness and these come in two forms
generally one form of these studies is
individuals come into a laboratory they
participate in an experiment over the
course of a day or months and then datar
collected analyzed and the papers are
submitted and published and discussed
the other form is so-called longitudinal
study where individuals come into the
laboratory and they are studied over a
very long period of time ranging from
months to years and sometimes even
decades
and then
the variables of age life circumstances
and other factors can be incorporated
into the data and typically there are
multiple papers there's data published
throughout the longitudinal study or
sometimes it's just one paper at the end
of the longitudinal study
let's talk about one of the more famous
and perhaps the longest running
longitudinal study on happiness this is
a study that was initiated or conceived
in 1938 at Harvard University the
so-called Harvard Happiness Project some
of you probably heard about this it
involved Harvard college sophomores and
other individuals were incorporated into
this study as well
it's a study that initially had more
than a couple of hundred subjects but
because some have either dropped out and
not been able to be contacted and
monitored over time or died or for
whatever reason are no longer
participating in the study there are
very few of these individuals left and
yet there's tremendous power to a study
like this it's such an impressive study
and we're also grateful that
Laboratories at Harvard decide to
initiate and continue this study
because it is one of the few studies
perhaps these study that has allowed us
to understand happiness in our species
over a very long period of time like any
study it's not perfect it didn't include
a lot of
um matching by sex or matching by
vocation or matching by income and
background and back then there was also
a lot less discussion about trauma and
histories around trauma as well as
positive episodes in people's lives
nonetheless there's a lot of power in a
study like this and there's some very
basic takeaways some of which you may
have heard before but some of which may
be surprising
those of you who haven't
so one of the key things about the study
is
people in the study at least those who
still have intact memory and which many
of them do are able to think back on not
just their previous year or week but 10
years ago 20 years ago 50 years ago and
compare what makes them happy at one age
versus another age a number of things
have emerged from that conversation so I
just want to discuss some of the
Highlight points then we'll get into a
little bit more of the nitty-gritty of
the data first of all it's been
discussed many many times that the total
amount of income that an individual
makes or has and again this could be
income from work or it could be money
that they inherited does not seem to
directly relate to their level of
Happiness now a lot of people take that
point and think ah money doesn't matter
other people hear that point and think
to themselves yeah right easy to say if
you have a lot of money
we'll talk about the interpretation of
those data in just a few minutes but I
do want to earmark that finding because
I agree that while money or total
resources itself does not predict
happiness in any kind of direct way
that is not the same thing as saying
having very few resources will make you
happier of course I don't think anyone
would imagine that but it also
tends to overlook an important point
which is something that I certainly have
learned to appreciate in my life and
something that I especially appreciated
when I was a student and postdoc which
is the following people will say money
can't buy happiness and we'll talk about
the buy aspect of that in a moment and
indeed that's true if you look at this
longitudinal study or you look at other
studies that are done on a more
short-term basis
once people get past a certain level of
income relative to their cost of living
the amount of happiness does not scale
with that income that is for every
additional thousand dollars or ten
thousand dollars that they earn they
don't report being that much happier on
a daily basis
now
that said
I Venture the argument that while money
truly cannot buy happiness it absolutely
can buffer stress and in particular it
can buffer stress in the form of the
ability to purchase or pay for goods and
services and in particular Services
you're not going to tell me that having
children doesn't involve some increase
in the demands on your life less sleep
and more demand and it certainly is the
case that if you can hire help to clean
you can hire nannies if that's your your
thing you can hire help to assist with
babysitting or even night nurses if
you're having trouble sleeping that will
literally allow you to sleep while they
take care of your child in the middle of
the night often give excellent care one
hopes excellent care that that won't
offset some of the stress associated
with lack of sleep so there are a
million different examples one could
give of this but I certainly experienced
this during graduate school in fact I
experienced both sides of the equation
here I made very little money as a
graduate student I had essentially no
savings when I started graduate school
and I made very little money the amount
doesn't matter at this point but I could
just barely afford rent in my food I
actually opted to live in the laboratory
a lot of the time
and by doing that I had more money to
spend on other things that were
important to me now I did not have a
family at the time and so I was able to
do that something that not everyone can
do but I made very little money
but at the same time I was in laboratory
all the time and that's where I wanted
to be and so my level of stress was
actually pretty low because I was
investing all my time and energy into
the very thing that I knew would
eventually help bring me more resources
when I moved from being a graduate
student to a postdoc for instance a
postdoc is a generally a three to five
year period so like residency and
Medicine where you're no longer taking
courses but you continue to do research
in fact entire new lines of research and
prior to getting a professorship
my income went up slightly went up by
about 30 to 40 percent but because of
where I moved and because of the times
my cost of living went way way up and I
was extremely stressed so it wasn't my
absolute income it was my absolute
income relative to my cost of living the
other thing that one needs to consider
when considering income versus cost of
living is there's also this notion of
peer group and we're going to talk more
about social bonds and connections later
but one thing I noticed when I moved
from being a graduate student to a
postdoc was I was a graduate student in
a small town where I had access if I
chose to participate in most if not all
of the social Gatherings because they
were all very low cost people tended to
aggregate at the Farmers Market on
Saturday most people wouldn't even
purchase anything at least not the The
Graduate students wouldn't purchase
anything it was just a place to
aggregate people sometimes play pickup
games of soccer or just hang out have a
cup of coffee
there was a volleyball game on Fridays
sometimes people would go out to eat
that evening which of course costs money
Etc but it was relatively low cost of
living and social connections and peer
group interactions were all generated
around the same fairly low-cost
activities when I transitioned to being
a postdoc
I made more money but Cost of Living
went up but in addition to that my peer
group tended to want to engage in the
same kinds of activities that people in
that larger city were engaged in so peer
group has a tremendously powerful
influence on whether or not we gauge the
amount of money that we have as bringing
us happiness or not and that really
speaks to the critical importance of
social interactions and certain kinds of
social interactions in particular now if
any of that was unclear what I'm
basically saying is it's not just about
being able to pay your rent it's also
about being able to access the kinds of
social interactions that you deem are
quote unquote correct for you at that
stage of life and in the place where you
happen to be living because if you can
meet all the demands of costs of rent
and paying your power bill and food Etc
but you are socially isolated because
your peer group or those around you that
you want to engage with are engaging in
activities that you either don't have
time for literally because you're doing
other things or that you don't have the
financial resources for then that can
actually severely impact this rating of
what we call happiness why am I parsing
this so finely well I'm parsing it
finally because I think that most of us
have heard the outcome of this study
from Harvard or the more short-term
studies also many of which are from
Harvard we'll talk about the just
phenomenal work from Dan Gilbert's
laboratory and other Laboratories who
have focused on issues like these and I
certainly don't want to take anything
away from those results they're very
powerful and important results that
really point over and over to the fact
that
people's happiness does not necessarily
scale with income in fact it tends not
to pass a certain level
and yet I think we'd be remiss I think
actually it would be inappropriate for
me to say that the amount of income that
one makes is not important because if
the amount of money that you happen to
have or are making
does not allow you to meet your basic
needs of shelter Health Care
Etc and or doesn't allow you to access
the kind of social interactions that can
renew and reset or I would say directly
enhance the kind of neurotransmitter
systems and hormones that lead us to
feel that we are happy in our life and
we're having Quality Social connections
well then that's very stressful and this
brings me back to the statement I made
earlier which is indeed money cannot buy
happiness but it certainly can buffer
stress and one of the ways that it
buffers stress is by allowing options of
different kinds of social interactions
options of different types of recreation
that one can engage in to access new
forms of social interaction and so on
and so on so we need to be a little bit
careful or at least nuanced about this
statement that money can't buy happiness
and that the data support the fact that
wealth doesn't determine happiness I
think there is a truth to that but
there's another side to that that I
think is less often and acknowledged and
that certainly I've experienced and that
I think many of you out there have
probably experienced as well one other
major finding of the Harvard
longitudinal study on happiness as well
as shorter term studies on happiness is
that much as you've heard perhaps that
no one on their deathbed says they wish
they had worked more
well indeed the total amount of time
that one spends working does not seem to
determine one's happiness and yet I also
want to earmark that result as one that
we need to parse a bit more carefully
because
work last time I checked and certainly
for me is the way typically that people
earn an income and as we just talked
about a moment ago income is often a way
that people have access to or provide
access for their family to things like
Recreation
that opens up the opportunity for more
social connection right so there we have
to be careful with how we interpret
these blanket statements that have
become very popular that you know money
doesn't determine happiness and that the
amount that you work isn't going to
determine happiness
it certainly is the case that if you
earn more money from working more and
that money is devoted to things that
bring more opportunities for social
connection or for buffering stress in
other areas of your life including
Health Care uh care for your children
care for yourself Recreation
other things that you enjoy well then I
think it's a little bit naive to assume
that work itself is somehow counter to
happiness which of course it isn't and
it especially isn't if we combine that
feature of work with another important
feature of the human psyche which is
this notion of meaning now in the not
too distant future we will do an episode
of this podcast on meaning and what
constitutes meaning in a given Endeavor
work or otherwise but
much of the psychology of the last
century and still today focuses on this
feature of meaning as a critical one in
terms of what makes us happy and what
doesn't make us happy certainly in the
long term and I can certainly say for
myself that learning and teaching and
doing research in my laboratory brings
me tremendous feeling of meaning and
happiness
some people consider their work simply a
way to gain a paycheck
and other people find that they would do
the very work they do regardless of
whether or not they were paid in fact
many people will do volunteer work and
other forms of work for zero money so
this idea that money isn't important or
that work is not as important as we deem
it to be that also needs to be
considered from a number of different
perspectives and again by no means am I
trying to undermine the data of these
impressive studies both the longitudinal
and short-term studies but
I think we do have to be cautious in our
discussion of results like these Because
the Internet is replete with
conversations about the big
factors that determine happiness it's
going to be social connection not income
it's going to be the amount of time that
you are able to have open thinking and
creativity which I think is an essential
feature of Happiness by the way physical
health in particular
one's ability to stay mobile and to be
able to access the kind of daily
activities that one needs to accomplish
unassisted is a strong correlate of
happiness
and so on and so on
and of course there are the basic
physiology factors the things that feed
back onto our overall feelings of
well-being and I've talked about these
before and we'll just put these quickly
into a bin you can think of this as a as
a tool kit of things that you and
everyone really should be constantly
trying to access if not optimize on a
regular basis because they raise the
tide or what I would call the buoyancy
of your overall system meaning your
brain and body and that would be getting
sufficient deep sleep at least 80
percent of the nights of your life and
ideally the remaining 20 you're not
getting deep sleep or as much of it
because of positive events
quality nutrition
quality social interactions and we will
Define that a little bit better in fact
we will Define that in a lot of detail
later in this episode and actually how
to get better at creating quality social
interactions even very brief social
interactions
so we have sleep we have nutrition we
have social interactions we have
purposeful work whether or not it's paid
work or non-paid work and of course
there are things like exercise and maybe
relationships to pets and things of that
sort and there are a few others as well
all of those are known to increase your
overall state of well-being that puts
you in a position to access more meaning
and happiness Etc but for most people I
think it's fair to say that earning a
living and earning a living by working
is the typical way in which we spend
most of our time so I think we need to
put a special bracket around those
activities and it's something we'll
return to a little bit later in terms of
trying to understand how periods of life
in which they're
are big or extensive work demands or
extensive family demands on us are
indeed compatible with states of
happiness or frequent states of
happiness and how better to access those
rather than simply say money isn't
important or the amount of time at work
really isn't important that's not what
people are going to pay attention to in
fact I don't know how I will feel on my
deathbed how could I
um human beings are pretty good about
understanding how they feel in the
present if not describing it they are
pretty good at feeling it if they have
any sense of internal state that is
interception you have some idea of how
you feel in a moment
we're pretty good about describing our
past
feelings at least in Broad Contour
but we are not very good at projecting
how we will feel in the future in fact
that's a theme that's going to come up
again and again today
nonetheless what we do know on the basis
of really solid data or that certain
aspects of our well-being tend to change
across our lifespan now lifespan is
something that we need to consider from
also a bit of nuance because humans are
indeed living longer and longer and if
we look at the data on happiness across
the lifespan
dated maybe 30 or 40 years back or even
20 years ago
it has consistently described in that
literature as a so-called u-shaped
function where people in their 20s
report being very very happy
But as time goes on and they acquire
more responsibility so typically getting
married and having children and their
mid to late 20s and 30s and into their
40s having more work demands Etc
happinesses tends to be rated lower and
lower at least in those previous studies
and then happiness tended to increase as
people approach their 50s and 60s and
they tended to retire and their work
demands were Shed from them and they
were able to enjoy the small things of
Life despite the fact that
in general I would say almost always
People's Health is not as vigorous when
they're 70 as it is when they're when
they're 20. they're exceptions to that
of course but and of course you can
adjust the rate of uh cognitive and
physical decline but in general people
in their 20s feel more physically and
mentally vigorous than they do in their
60s and 70s in general that u-shaped
function that I just described still
holds true today but of course there
have been some major shifts to the
general life stages and when people
undergo those life stages for instance
many people are getting married much
later many people are opting to not have
children in fact if you look at the data
on whether or not people have children
or not and how that relates to happiness
everyone will tell you that their kids
are their greatest source of Joy at
least most people will tell you that and
are a tremendous source of happiness
it's obvious kids are delightful and
raising kids while hard is a wonderful
experience
if you look at the ratings of Happiness
among people that elected elected to not
have children versus those that had most
people who have children report their
overall levels of happiness as lower
than that of people who opt not to have
children now there are a lot of ways to
interpret those findings and by no means
am I encouraging people to not have
children
all right that's a issue that you have
to resolve for yourself of course but
we could imagine for instance that
people who opt not to have children have
more income to devote to things more
focused on themselves or their partner
or other aspects of their life
we don't know if that's the underlying
reason we could perhaps conclude that
people who opt not to have children are
getting more sleep on a regular basis or
have more time for exercise or the other
sorts of things that elevate states of
mood and well-being again we do not know
what the underlying reasons are for this
finding but it does seem that despite
most every parent reporting that their
kids are their greatest source of joy
and quote unquote happiness in life that
people who opt not to have children are
at least as happy or report being at
least as happy or even happier than
those
that opt to have children and of course
I'm I want to be very clear that I'm not
trying to
um settle any arguments about whether or
not people should have children or not I
happen to find children and animals
delightful
um and I'm always happy when people opt
to have children provided they are
taking good care of their children or or
doing their very best to take good care
of their children so that's my stance
but of course you're all entitled to
your own stance on this they're also the
general arguments that people like to
have about whether or not the population
of the Earth will be sustained or not
sustained based on current birth rates
Etc indeed many areas of the world birth
rates are going down
is actually something that
um just as a perhaps point of Interest
has been studied from the uh somewhat
unusual but um a logical perspective of
whether or not child diapers are selling
at the same rate as they were some years
ago and whether or not adult diapers for
the elderly are being sold at the same
rate or or greater that if you think
about it is one indirect measure of
whether or not people are living longer
and or um opting to have children
definitely in discussion for another
time probably for another podcast
entirely I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge one of our sponsors
athletic greens athletic greens now
called ag1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs I've been
taking athletic greens since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be in the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 so this
u-shaped function of
people being happier earlier in life and
then reporting feeling far less happy
and then happiness returning to them
that is the rising of the you again in
their later years is something that I do
believe should be repeated in Modern
Times And repeated in a way that takes
into account that that you might be
shifted to the right that is
I am certainly aware that people are
tending to get married later many are
opting to not have children so for
instance the the question arises whether
or not that U-shaped curve should have a
bump down at the bottom of the U among
those that opt not to have children
because the argument was made in the
discussion of those papers that the
reason why happiness is lower when
people are in their 30s 40s and 50s is
because they're devoting more time to
raising their children
and devoting more time to work uh I
would hope people would enjoy their work
but not everybody really enjoys their
work and many people even if they do
enjoy their work and they find meaning
in it still find it stressful which
certainly can run counter to happiness
nowadays you could imagine that because
a number of people are opting perhaps to
work less or to not have children or
both
where they find tremendous meaning from
their work that there would be a bump at
the bottom of that you among those that
decided to simply not take on these
additional responsibilities that would
be an interesting test I think of
whether or not the total load of
responsibility is really what's
correlating with reported happiness or
not now one very consistent finding that
has absolutely stood the test of time
it's kind of an interesting one it's a
little bit of a pop psychology finding
but I think it points to something
interesting that we'll return to again
and again is that people tend to report
feeling lower levels of happiness
believe it or not on their birthday
and the argument for why this is
is the following that typically we go
through our year not comparing ourselves
to our peers terribly much
we might do that a little bit more when
we're in elementary school high school
Etc we're sort of age match maybe even
College as well but in evaluation of
ourselves to our age match peers is not
typically something that we do on a
daily basis
whereas on our birthday we get a
snapshot of where we are in the Arc of
time or at least in our life and many
people report feeling rather low on
their birthday because they use that as
a benchmark or a window into the things
that they have not accomplished the
things that despite being age blank they
still haven't accomplished and so that's
interesting because what it really
points to is two things one the extent
to which much of our feelings of
Happiness are relative in particular
relative to our peers so there's that
social aspect again and
the fact that most of the time we are
not very good at orienting ourselves in
the longer Arc of time we're pretty good
at knowing where we are in the Arc of a
day or the Arc of a week or the Arc of a
month or even a year but that most of us
are not very good at reflecting on where
we are in our life Arc and of course
most of us don't know how long we will
live anyway but we do have some general
sense I mean very few people live past
the age of 100
many people live to be 70 or 80 and
again life span is
extending as far as we know from year to
year
but in general people report that on
their birthdays and I should say these
are for birthdays aged 25 or later
at least in the studies I was able to
access right I don't think that a lot of
three-year-olds sit around comparing
themselves to other three-year-olds and
how well they're doing or 12 year olds
you can imagine some people might do
that at 18 Etc but it's really by the
mid-20s that people start evaluating
themselves to their peers in terms of
Life progression and so-called
Milestones it's been argued that that's
one of the reasons why people report
lower affect lower levels of happiness
on their birthday something that's a
little bit counter-intuitive and of
course there are things that are
anti-correlated with happiness you know
I'd be remiss if I didn't mention a few
of these that's longitudinal study the
Harvard Happiness Project
has reported for instance that people
that are chronic smokers of nicotine and
chronic consumers of alcohol in
particular alcoholics that is people who
suffer from alcoholism or what sometimes
called alcohol use disorder
that is strongly anti-correlated with
happiness and I should also mention that
the family members and in particular the
Romantic partners of people who are
chronic smokers
and the partners of people who are
chronic alcohol users often will report
lower levels of happiness especially if
they themselves are not chronic smokers
or regular consumers of alcohol
so we've done episodes on nicotine in
particular and that touched on smoking
of course and we've done an episode on
alcohol and the effects of alcohol on
health again you can find those at
hubermanlab.com this study from the
Harvard Happiness Project
really has strong data supporting the
fact that avoiding being a nicotine
smoker right there are positive health
effects of nicotine that are discussed
in the episode nicotine but being a but
smoking nicotine in particular is
counterproductive for people's at least
self-reported happiness and certainly
overall health I think there's zero
question that smoking increases cancers
over different kinds and that alcohol
consumption in particular alcohol
consumption Beyond two drinks per week
two drinks being the typical volume of
you know a beer glass of wine or a
cocktail Etc is detrimental for various
aspects of health and of course there
are other things that you could imagine
would relate to a lack of happiness for
instance a major trauma physical or
emotional trauma uh that could include
the loss of a major relationship a death
of a close one
um being the victim of a violent crime
and things of that sort and yet it's
been argued in fact strongly argued that
when you look at people's levels of
happiness
after a trauma that
if you wait about a year or so sometimes
as even as short as three months after a
trauma that people self-reported levels
of happiness are not significantly lower
than they were prior to the trauma now I
very much want to highlight underline
and bold and asterisks that statement as
one that we really need to explore
carefully because there are other data
that strongly point to the fact that
major life traumas can severely disrupt
one sense of happiness and well-being
and I think as long as we're going to
have this discussion we should point to
a useful definition of trauma and the
definition that I'll paraphrase is one
that was
supplied by a former guest on the human
Lab podcast Dr Paul Conte who's a
psychiatrist who's written a book called
trauma I personally think it's the best
book on trauma and tools for alleviating
trauma it's incredibly thorough easy to
read and well informed and
here again I'm paraphrasing but Dr Conti
describes trauma as something that
fundamentally changes the way that our
brain and body function in a way that
makes other aspects of living more
challenging
again an event either emotional or
physical or both that fundamentally
changes the way that our brain and or
body that is our our nervous system and
other organs function
in a way that prevents us from enjoying
daily activities and that could even be
ongoing distraction right traumas can
create rumination or they can create
obsessive thought or they can create
dissociation any number of different
things again check out that episode with
Dr Paul Conte if you'd like to learn
more about trauma and how it manifests
but
the idea that's been put forth by a
number of researchers in the in the
field of happiness that three months
after a major trauma people aren't
reporting that they are feeling any less
happy than before the trauma that was
surprising to me so I I went into this
literature a bit more deeply one of the
basis of that General line of thinking
is a what I consider now classic and
very important and frankly excellent
talk that was given by Professor Dan
Gilbert on the science of happiness you
can find this on YouTube I say a classic
one because it was it was done some
years ago it's received you know
millions of views and one of the points
that he makes in that talk which is
grounded in research carried out by his
laboratory and other Laboratories is
that
you know he poses a question he says you
know let's do a quiz would you rather be
someone who wins the lottery and he
shows a picture of somebody who just won
I think it was several hundreds of
millions of dollars in the lottery or
was recently made paraplegic lost use of
their legs
and
then goes on to state that one year
after people have won the lottery this
major you know monetary windfall versus
have become paraplegic is that their
self-reported levels of happiness are
the same which I think is incredibly
surprising now I heard this and I
immediately thought of an experience
that I've had where I teach a course at
Stanford school of medicine on neural
regeneration and it's actually a course
that I attended some years ago when I
was a postdoc at Stanford so well over a
decade ago and we had excuse me we had
an individual come into the course this
was a an older gentleman so older
meaning he was in his early 70s and he
had become paraplegic fairly late in
life from a cycling accident and he was
and is an expert in
what it is to become a paraplegic of
course because he had that experience
but also because he spends a lot of his
time doing volunteer work with people
who have become paraplegic and have
become paraplegic at different ages and
what he described to me was that the
overall outcomes for people that are
rendered paraplegic in terms of their
mental health and their physical
well-being
there are sort of management of General
life skills scales with how early they
had that injury and how long they had
the use of their limbs so it's not
straightforward
when I heard this result described by
Dr Dan Gilbert that winning the lottery
and becoming paraplegic basically don't
impact your levels of happiness to any
uh different degree when you know people
look back a year later I was pretty
surprised given my experience of hearing
this this lecture at Stanford so I
thought wow from what I understand
indeed there are people who are rendered
paraplegic and manage that transition
very easily it doesn't seem to disrupt
their feelings of well-being Etc but for
other people it can be severely
disrupting to their sense of well-being
and so on and so forth
I went back and examined these data and
in fact a subsequent talk it's actually
a podcast that was given by Dr Dan
Gilbert some years later so this would
be just a few years ago I think in 2019
is a specific date in which it was
recorded but just a few years ago and
indeed he corrects himself in that
podcast what he says is that he misspoke
in that earlier talk that
the difference in self-reported levels
of happiness for those that have been
rendered paraplegic for versus those
who've won the lottery
is not as great as one would expect you
know I think most people would expect
that being rendered paraplegic would
make people far less happy that's the
expectation I think anyway and that
people would win the lottery at least
for some period of time would be far
happier than they were prior to winning
the lottery especially given the
tremendous amount of money and again the
fact that money can't buy happiness but
that money does indeed enable the
ability to buffer stress provided people
we're responsible with that money and
just didn't blow it or spend it all
right away that they could start to
afford things that they couldn't afford
not just in terms of luxury items but
also the ability to hire help that would
free up time that would allow them to do
anything from uh travel that they
couldn't access before to meditate if
that was something that they didn't have
time to do before and so on and so forth
so the result quote unquote that winners
of the lottery and recent paraplegics
have the same levels of happiness is
actually not true at least according to
the author of the original study now
what he did not point to is the degree
to which that is not true but he did
point to the direction of the result and
the fact that people who are rendered
paraplegic in fact are reporting
themselves as
less happy than they were prior to their
injury and certainly that their levels
of happiness are lower than those uh
that simply won the lottery hundreds of
millions of dollars which I think is the
more intuitive result and so I think
it's important to be aware of of that
discrepancy because it's something that
was lost in the communication
um around those results the first time
around and indeed um Dan Gilbert is an
excellent scientist and and was uh quite
good about trying to correct the
narrative I myself as a podcaster who
puts information on the internet know
that the challenges of correcting
narratives especially of things that
that came out some time ago we always
attempt to do this as best we can but
not everyone that saw that first video
will necessarily hear the discussion
that happened subsequently so my hope is
um that Dr Gilbert will interpret me
communicating this now not as an attempt
to criticize him but rather as an
attempt to praise His willingness to try
and correct the narrative to be more
accurate so to be very clear about what
this study did and didn't show and here
I'm going to come Vine these results
with other studies that I was able to
find that explored similar phenomena so
major trauma for instance not
necessarily becoming paraplegic but
traumas of a different sort emotional
traumas when you look at the whole of
those data at least my read is that when
people win the lottery or acquire wealth
through inheritance some form of wealth
acquisition that is sudden and that
wasn't preceded by a specific effort to
gain that wealth right buying a lottery
ticket is a pretty quick thing
inheritance is something that you simply
get by virtue of who you are not
necessarily by effort
well that led to increases in
self-reported happiness
compared to prior to the inheritance of
the lottery win but it wasn't as
substantial as you might imagine if
you're approaching the notion of
Happiness simply from well more money
equals more happiness and
while it is true that people who are
rendered paraplegic who or who undergo
psychological traumas or physical
traumas of any various kind
are and frankly are remarkably resilient
in many cases they can still manage to
go about life and and work and engage in
relationships Etc
there is a visible decrease in overall
levels of happiness and well-being in
particular if the psychological and
physical trauma renders their
nervous system different in a way that
impacts other major areas of life and
enjoyment for them
and that's certainly true one year out
from the trauma so the point is that we
do need to reframe this idea that
whether or not you win the lottery or
become paraplegic or suffer some major
trauma your levels of happiness are
going to be the same three months or a
year later I don't think that's accurate
and in fact
Dr Dan Gilbert emphasized that that's
not accurate
um even in that initial study and I
think it's an important thing to frame
because that's such a popular notion or
that that idea combined with the idea
that increased earnings don't make us
happy combined with the idea that you
know we are happy early in life
um but then as more demands arise in
life we become less happy and then we
become happy again and and that idea is
we already explored is not necessarily
true frankly I knew a lot of teenagers
and people in their their early 20s are
pretty unhappy who then become happier
later as they acquire more resources
sometimes distance let's be honest
sometimes distance from our family of
origin makes us more happy sometimes
less so it's highly individual so I
think those General themes that we've
heard over and over while they have
Merit and they certainly stand up in
some of the more powerful longitudinal
and short-term studies there is nuance
and in some cases there are now
additional data that are causing us to
revise those understandings now there is
an important point or I should say the
important point that we can really
credit Dan Gilbert and others in the
field of psychology with and that we owe
them a great debt of gratitude for is
that
we do have far more control over our
levels of happiness than we might think
and
many of the things that reside at that
level of control that is the things that
we can do and think and say and access
don't come from external things right
they don't come necessarily from the
acquisition of material Goods
but rather there are things that we can
do that can allow us to so-called
synthesize happiness and I think this is
one of the great gifts of modern
psychology is that Dan Gilbert and
others the Harvard Happiness Project
work at Yale and elsewhere right there
excellent Labs working on happiness all
over the U.S and and all over the world
frankly
one of the great gifts that they've
supplied Us in the form of data is that
there really are things that we can all
do and think and access to allow
ourselves to so-called synthesize
happiness now this notion of synth
synthesizing happiness or synthetic
happiness is sometimes called
can sometimes ruffle people's feathers a
bit because
people immediately flip to the idea that
oh you're just going to tell me to be
grateful for what I have or to just
Naval gaze or just to imagine that I'm
happy but that's really not What
synthetic happiness is about at all
synthetic happiness actually has to do
with some really important larger
principles about the way that our
emotional system and the way that the
reward systems of our brain really
function and they point to important
Concepts that we're going to now discuss
things like the hedonic set point for
instance or the dopamine system of
anticipation of rewards versus receiving
words just as a brief insight into that
our anticipation of something positive
oftentimes leads to Greater increases in
the sorts of neurochemicals that support
a state of happiness and well-being than
the actual acquisition of
the thing that we're trying to obtain
and this goes back to a theme I've
discussed a few times before in this
podcast in particular with my colleague
at Stanford School of Medicine Dr Anna
Lemke who wrote The Fabulous book
dopamine Nation if you're interested in
dopamine and addiction in particular
that's a wonderful clear and extremely
informative read and if you're
interested in dopamine more generally
just not just in the states of addiction
but in everyday life and in Pursuit and
motivation the molecule of more is an
excellent book related to that and as I
mentioned earlier we have this episode
on dopamine motivation and drive
the
the notion of synthetic happiness
is not simply about imagining happiness
or thinking about happiness or
anticipating happiness to some extent it
is but it relates to a number of other
important themes but it is grounded very
thoroughly in the neurobiology of
dopamine rewards and I'll talk about
some of that neurobiology in a few
moments but
I want to take a couple of minutes and
talk about what synthetic happiness is
and what some of the conditions are for
allowing us to access this state of
so-called synthetic happiness and I want
to point out at the outset that
synthetic happiness while it might sound
synthetic AKA false it's anything but it
actually turns out to be among the more
and perhaps the more potent form of
happiness that we can all access and
this is where themes
in related to our control over our own
internal State really become not only
valid but very powerful so for instance
Dr Dan Gilbert and others have explored
how opportunity and choice that is
freedom
can and can't lead to states of
happiness and the results of those
studies are very solid and frankly very
surprising until you understand the
results and once you do I think you will
immediately see areas of your own life
that you can start to access more
happiness again genuine happiness simply
by Framing certain choices in a
particular way and maybe even by
eliminating choices now I'd like to
focus on the research aimed at
understanding what increases our levels
of happiness and I'd like to frame this
under the umbrella of two major themes
the First theme is so-called natural
happiness natural happiness is the sort
of happiness that most of us are
familiar with so the kind of happiness
that we expect to have if we for
instance complete a degree hopefully a
degree in a topic meaningful and
interesting to us but a degree
nonetheless or we find a mate hopefully
a mate that we enjoy spending time with
or for instance making a certain income
or finding work that we enjoy on a
regular basis all of those are forms of
happiness that from a very early time in
development we are taught exist for
instance even when we are very young we
are told that our birthday is coming and
that we are going to get presents and
those presents are going to be focused
on knowledge of things that we already
enjoy so if you're a little kid and you
like trucks or you're a little kid and
you like dolls
you can sort of expect that those gifts
will bring you some level of Joy or
happiness and while that's a small child
example that General notion of natural
happiness is of course one that persists
into adolescence into young adulthood
and into adulthood and we quite
understandably come to associate this
feeling of Joy or happiness with the
receiving of things or the acquisition
of things whether by effort by gift by
inheritance or some other form okay so
that's natural happiness and yet as I
mentioned a little bit earlier
there's also this notion of synthetic
happiness and some of the more
interesting and exciting research in the
fields of psychology and in fact
Neuroscience point to this idea of
synthetic happiness as at least as
powerful a source of Happiness As
Natural happiness again at least as
powerful and perhaps even more powerful
and of course one has to take a slightly
different view of What happiness is in
order to accept this idea that we can
create happiness for ourselves but
that doesn't mean that the whole notion
of synthetic happiness is merely a
passive one where all we do is sit back
and imagine being happy and then we are
happy for better for worse our nervous
systems and our neurochemistry simply
don't work that way in fact synthetic
happiness has almost always been
understood as something that we have to
put some effort toward achieving but and
this is an important thing to point out
synthetic happiness also requires that
certain situational or environmental
conditions be met
a good example of this is some of the
work by Jillian mandich or I should say
Dr Jillian mandich who's done some
interesting work on the conditions for
creating happiness within our mind and
in our overall state of being
and she's been involved in a number of
different studies but one of the ones
that I found particularly interesting is
one in which they explored different
types of music and other aspects of
environmental settings so you bring
subjects to the laboratory play them
different types of music there are in
fact certain aspects of music that can
create different states of Mind sadness
happiness anticipation in fact there are
certain patterns of music that can
reliably induce anticipation of the fear
and anxiety based type so for instance
think the movie Jaws if you recall for
those of you that seen Jaws there's this
ongoing theme music anytime the shark
might be present in the water or in a
given scene that essentially goes
now for the musicians out there this has
bassists and things like tritones and
things that are understood from the
mathematics and the and the musical side
and from the Neuroscience side are known
to create a neural state of anticipation
yeah a neural state of anticipation and
not necessarily A positive one and
indeed there are other patterns
of music that involve up tones think
some of the music that's typically been
used in cartoons of various sorts
there's a long history of this indeed
there's a whole literature of
psychological and now even a smaller but
still interesting literature on the
Neuroscience of how certain patterns of
Music can induce a state of joy and
joyful anticipation in particular a lot
of those patterns of Music are
incorporated into so-called happy
cartoons and Disney movies and things of
that sort in any case
Dr mandich and others have explored how
music in particular but other features
of the environment
can or cannot induce states of happiness
and the basic takeaway from those
studies is that
while having a certain Environmental
sound musical tone or visual
feature to a given space a room
is necessary for a state of happiness it
is not alone sufficient what is required
is that individuals not only be placed
into an environment that contains music
or visual items
or a combination of music and visual
items that can induce states of Joy or
happiness or positive anticipation but
that they also
are given some sort of instruction or
instruction manual as to how to
synthesize happiness inside of that
environment
this is important because what this says
is that our ability to create states of
happiness is dependent on our
environment but also requires effort
from us
that also makes sense as to why when we
are under conditions of deprivation so
it could be social deprivation or
financial deprivation or even for people
that are very sensitive to weather you
know there are a certain number of
individuals about 30 percent of people
who report feeling very very low under
conditions where the sky is overcast
especially if it's been overcast for a
number of days the so-called Seasonal
effective depression those individuals
by the way can often receive tremendous
benefits in terms of elevating their
mood if they make an effort to get
sunlight if they can't get sunlight
artificial light of the sort that we
talked about earlier
but in any case
there are a number of people that are
profoundly negatively influenced by the
lack of positive Visual and auditory
cues in their environment but for most
people we are in a what I would call a
dynamic relationship with our
environment our environment has an
effect on our mood but the Research
indicates that we also need to make some
sort of effort toward being happy now
effort toward being happy is a very
vague term so let's better Define what
that is
in the case of Dr mandich's work this
took the form of doing so-called
happiness inventories right that can be
focusing on things that one is grateful
for
um things that they particularly enjoy
this is somewhat of a gratitude type
practice but includes some other
features as well that are more focused
on the things that bring you meaning and
actually engaging in the things that
bring you meaning so if you're trying to
think about how to improve your levels
of happiness
what this research essentially says is
that you would be smart to try and
adjust your home environment adjust your
work environment so that it is cheerful
to you maybe that means a plant for me
in my laboratory one of the things that
was really critical that I had as a
postdoc and in my own Laboratory
when I first started my lab was I love
Aquaria so I had multiple fish tanks in
fact people in my laboratory were always
rolling their eyes why do we have to
have all these fish tanks with all these
I like fresh water tanks not salt water
tanks for reasons that aren't
interesting for this discussion but
freshwater tanks with discus fish for
instance to me are just beautiful they
make me happy I just enjoy them
um music is a complicated thing in
Laboratories because it's a shared space
so headphones are the general
requirement but having either silence if
you love silence and I happen to like
working in silence or listening to
certain forms of music I do also use the
40 Hertz binaural beats or I
particularly like listening to Glenn
Gould while I work or listening to whale
song Believe It or Not while I work
because it doesn't have any structure
that I can follow I don't speak whale
and so I can't follow but it sort of
fills the space in a way that I find
Pleasant and I've put substantial
amounts of effort into making my
laboratory spaces and my office spaces
my workspaces nice places to be now I
had no knowledge of this work from Dr
mandich and others at the time when I
did that but what I found was that over
the years I I was challenged in
maintaining a kind of elevated mood
while working in a laboratory not
because I didn't thoroughly enjoy the
work I love doing experiments with my
hands and I loved being in lab but at
least the labs that I was in as a
graduate student in postdoc there were
no windows so I wasn't getting adequate
Sunshine the windows that we didn't have
didn't open so I wasn't getting a lot of
fresh air and so on and so forth so I've
personally found it very valuable to
create an environment both at work and
at home that I find aesthetically
Pleasant
at least in some way or another and I
realize people have varying levels of
control over the aesthetic environment
certainly the auditory environment can
be controlled nowadays through the use
of headphones if you're allowed to use
those so for instance using music or
using background sound that you find
very pleasant
combined with a concerted effort on your
part to
create states of Happiness by hopefully
doing work that's meaningful to you or
at least is leading to meaningful
outcomes we'll talk a little bit more
about that but these happiness
inventories also turn out to be
interesting and important sources of
creating so-called synthetic happiness
and we will also talk about other ways
that one can create elevated levels of
synthetic happiness and I realize the
word synthetic probably draws up
connotations of false happiness or
contrived happiness I wish instead of
calling it synthetic happiness they had
called it self-created or self-directed
happiness or something of that sort
because then it wouldn't sound as false
because it it's simply not false it
leads to the same
as far as we know identical
neurochemical and psychological states
of happiness is natural happiness and
might even be more persistent than
natural happiness it certainly is more
under our control but the key point is
that environment and
self-directed work at being happy are
both important and they interact with
one another so if you're somebody who
has a hard time synthesizing happiness
through any of the methods that we talk
about today
don't consider yourself deficient it
could very well be that the environment
that you're in social environment or
physical environment or auditory
environment is simply not conducive to
synthesizing happiness and for that
reason I think the work of Jillian
mandich and colleagues and others in the
field is tremendously important because
it removes us from this pressure to just
synthesize happiness from within despite
our circumstances I think you know many
of us have heard of the incredible
stories of people like Victor Frankl or
Nelson Mandela who were stripped of
their freedom and yet managed to
maintain some sense of positive
anticipation or at least some sense of
identity that allowed them to still
access forms of Happiness those are
highly unique situations of course and
they speak to the the power of the of
the human psyche for synthesizing
happiness and certainly for synthesizing
a sense that there might be a future and
to live into that future in in their
cases incredibly impressive ways but I
think for most everybody the environment
that we're in has a powerful impact on
our mood and some people more than
others you know I know people that are
perfectly happy with blank walls no
pictures on the walls other people
benefit tremendously from having photos
or plants in their environment and so on
you really have to determine what's
needed for you and do your best to try
and place those things into your
environment or rather Place yourself
into an environment that is conducive to
you synthesizing your happiness in fact
the powerful interaction between our
environment and our own ability to
generate certain kinds of emotions
is well established not just for
happiness but for things like gratitude
so for instance there's a classic study
from Ames Ames in 2004 that was focused
on gratitude and we've had an episode on
gratitude before
um the basic takeaway of that episode is
that it turns out receiving gratitude
is a more powerful stimulus for the
release of neurochemicals and activation
of brain areas associated with so-called
pro-social behaviors and feelings of
well-being including happiness but also
observing stories in the form of movies
or books or other narratives of other
people receiving help is also a very
powerful stimulus for gratitude also
giving gratitude is very powerful but
not as powerful as receiving gratitude
at least that's what the research says
or observing powerful exchanges of
gratitude between other individuals what
the study from Ames showed is that
gratitude as a state of mind and as an
emotion
does not exist in a vacuum it's not
independent of our surrounding so for
instance just writing down all the
things you're grateful for while it has
some positive impact the impact of that
or receiving gratitude or observing
gratitude is far more potent right
bigger increases in happiness and
feelings of well-being and indeed
neurochemicals and activation of brain
areas associated with happiness and
well-being when there's a reciprocity
when the person receiving is understand
something about the person that's giving
to them and understands that the person
is giving genuinely for instance so
there's an environmental interaction
it's not just about receiving it's
receiving from somebody that you know
genuinely wants to give and likewise for
The Giver in that equation the feelings
of well-being are far greater when the
person receiving whatever it is money
food
assistance in some form or another it
could be you know physical assistance
Etc
when The Giver has knowledge that the
person receiving it genuinely needed the
thing that they are receiving so the
important finding within the research
again and again is that happiness
doesn't exist in a vacuum it's partially
our own responsibility to synthesize
happiness you know I was told that many
times your life happiness is in your
head well yes indeed it's in your head
but it's also dependent on interactions
with your environment physical
environment and social environment and
so on likewise gratitude is something
that we can create inside of us right
through gratitude lists and appreciation
or we can give both powerful sources of
evoking
neurochemical changes associated with
gratitude and happiness and well-being
but it too doesn't exist in a vacuum
there's a much greater positive effect
when we have knowledge about why the
giver is giving us something or that the
person receiving something is going to
benefit tremendously from receiving it
so I'm highlighting this because I think
that when we hear about synthetic
happiness
there's a kind of automatic erasing of
context that tends to occur in fact if
you were to peruse the various videos
online or papers that exist on PubMed
around happiness and synthetic happiness
in particular you would come away with
the impression that synthetic happiness
is just something that we're supposed to
snap our fingers and access or perhaps
do very specific things in Access but
while that is true context really
matters and I think that's an important
Point much in the same way that the
point needs to be made that while money
doesn't buy happiness money can buffer
stress and certainly offer opportunities
that can provide opportunities for more
happiness so I think we are starting to
arrive at a general theme here which is
that nothing related to our mood exists
in isolation and in fact that leads me
to a discussion of one of the major
scientific findings in the realm of what
sorts of mindsets and behaviors
can in fact lead to happiness and this
is a paper that was published in 2008
even though that might seem like a while
ago it forms the basis for a large
amount of literature that followed it's
a very interesting literature this is
work from Elizabeth Dunn and colleagues
and was published in the journal science
which again is one of the sort of three
Apex journals nature science cell I
always say is sort of the Super Bowl NBA
championships and Stanley Cup of
scientific publishing very very
stringent in terms of the number of
papers they let in very few that is and
the title of this paper makes fairly
obvious what the paper is about the
title of the paper is spending money on
others promotes happiness and I know a
number of you probably hear that title
and think oh boy here we go he's going
to tell us that giving away all our
money is going to make us happier than
receiving money and I promise you that
is not what I'm going to tell you but
nonetheless this is a very interesting
study and it's one that I think that we
really ought to pay attention to because
what the study is based on is the fact
that
income provided one's income meets a
certain level of basic needs indeed has
been shown to have only a weak effect on
overall happiness
okay so quoting from the paper in the
first paragraph quote income has a
reliable but surprisingly weak effect on
happiness within nations with the
Nations just mean they looked at this in
not just the United States but a number
of other places as well particularly
once basic needs are met okay so if
that's the case then what aspects of
money and having money are related to
happiness certainly there are people who
have a lot of money who are very happy
certainly there are people who have very
little money who are very happy and of
course the reverse is also true there
are plenty of people who don't have very
much money who are unhappy and in fact
there are people who have a lot of money
who are very unhappy
a point that whenever
um It's Made often leads those with less
money to kind of roll their eyes because
the assumption is more money does
increase happiness and in fact it
doesn't and later we'll get back to this
idea of weather or how one acquired
their money has any impact on whether or
not that money increases their happiness
or not okay let's kind of earmark that
for later in the meantime let's talk a
little bit more about the findings in
this paper this paper is interesting
because
what it did is it explored something
called pro-social spending Pro social
spending is a phenomenon where people
are taking a certain portion of their
income and they are giving it to others
often for causes or for things that they
think are important to see happen in the
world or change in the world that could
be you know a hungry individual having
access to food or medical care it could
be for environmental causes it could be
for Animal Wellness it could be for any
number of different things it could even
be giving somebody money so that they
can buy themselves a gift or giving
somebody money and not having any excuse
me understanding or expectation of what
they're going to do with the money okay
again one of the central themes around
gratitude is that while
receiving is great giving is also great
in terms of increasing sense of
well-being
and one of the more important features
to that is when we give either in the
form of words or in the form of
resources
knowledge that the person receiving
benefits from that in some real way
greatly increases the chance that
there's an increase in happiness for The
Giver as well as the receiver again
that's a note about gratitude but not an
insignificant one as it relates to this
study so what this study found was that
higher pro-social spending was
associated with significantly greater
happiness this was a very statistically
significant effect and they found that
the effects of income and pro-social
spending were independent and similar in
magnitude okay
independent and similar magnitude I'll
explain what that means for those of you
that might be confused by that statement
in just a moment whereas quote personal
spending remained unrelated to happiness
so what this study basically found was
if people are allotted a certain amount
of money to give away
and one adjusts for overall income right
and this is important because you can
imagine that for some
individual giving away two thousand
dollars might represent a significant
portion of their yearly or monthly
income and for another individual it
might represent a tiny fraction
of their income but when you adjust for
income level what you find is that
people who gave away money
benefited tremendously in terms of their
own increase in happiness
in fact quote employees who devoted more
of their bonuses to pro-social spending
that is giving way more money experience
greater happiness after receiving the
bonus and the manner in which they spent
that bonus was a more important
predictor of their happiness than the
size of the bonus itself this was an
actual experiment they ran with real
income real money
I'm going to read that again just to
make sure it hits home because I found
this to be really impactful
employees who devoted a greater fraction
of their bonus
to pro-social spending
that is giving away money to others
experience greater happiness after
receiving the bonus and the manner in
which they spent that bonus was a more
important predictor of their happiness
than the size of the bonus itself so the
actual bonus the receiving of the money
led to Greater increases in happiness if
they gave it away
and the act of giving it away itself led
to Greater increases in happiness than
receiving the bonus
so it's a twofer as you might say so the
takeaway from this study and studies
like it I think is pretty obvious that
um to the extent that we can and again
when I say to the extent that we can
this means whatever percentage of our
own income that we can afford to give
away or if we don't have income the
percentage of our effort right I mean
this was about money but it's also about
effort we can help others right you can
serve in food kitchens you can do
community gardening you can pick up
trash you can do any number of of things
you can assist a neighbor with child
care or an assistant neighbor who is
physically less able to retrieve their
paper Etc et cetera it the point is that
giving resources certainly in the form
of money but also in the form of effort
and time
is immensely beneficial for synthesizing
our own happiness that is for the giver
us to increase our levels of happiness
but the degree of increase in our own
happiness is proportional in some way to
the extent to which the person receiving
actually needed that help and registers
that help excellent research also points
to the fact that another potent way to
synthesize happiness that is to create
genuine states of happiness in ourselves
is to leverage the so-called Focus
system or rather I should say to
de-emphasize the tendency of our minds
to wander there's an excellent paper on
this also published in the journal
science this is now a classic paper I
talked a little bit about it in the
episode on meditation but for those of
you that did or perhaps didn't hear that
episode I just want to briefly touch on
a few aspects of the paper
and and in particular a few aspects of
the paper that I didn't talk about
previously and the title of this paper
again is very straightforward in terms
of telling you what it's about and that
is a Wandering mind is an unhappy Mind
by Killingsworth and Gilbert this paper
was published in science in 2010 and we
will provide a link to the paper this is
frankly a very interesting paper this
paper involved several thousand subjects
or I should say 2250 adult subjects and
what they were able to do was to contact
these subjects while they were going
about living their daily lives
and ask them both what they were doing
and what they were feeling there were
some additional questions that they
asked them but
they were able to establish whether or
not people were watching television or
doing housework or working on a home
computer or resting or listening to
music Etc in their natural environment
so this is outside the laboratory and
they were able to assess
to what extent those people were happy
or unhappy or neutral
or had some other emotional state at the
time when they were engaging in any
number of different activities and they
assessed whether or not
those individuals were also focused on
or focused away from whatever activity
they were engaging in and the takeaways
from this study are many but for sake of
today's discussion
what I think is especially interesting
is that
regardless of whether or not people were
engaging in activities that they enjoyed
or not
the tendency for their mind to wander
from an activity predicted lower levels
of happiness than if they tended to be
focused on the activity they were
engaged in
now that itself should be surprising I
mean what that says is that even if
somebody was engaged in activity like
cleaning their house or doing homework
or reading something that they weren't
enjoying if they were focused on what
they were doing they tended to report as
happier than if their mind was drifting
elsewhere now this also points to the
idea that perhaps our minds drift to
unpleasant thoughts more than pleasant
thoughts but they also addressed that in
the study point I'd like to make here is
quote although people's minds were more
likely to wander to Pleasant topics okay
than to unpleasant topics and there that
the difference is pretty significant
people's minds tended to wander to
Pleasant topics about 43 of the time as
opposed to unpleasant topics about 27 of
the time or to neutral topics in the
remaining 31 of samples people were no
happier when thinking about Pleasant
topics than about their current activity
think about that people were no happier
than when thinking about Pleasant things
than their current activity in fact the
mere focus on what they were doing
was more powerful than anything else
even if they didn't enjoy what they were
doing so they go on here to say quote
although negative moods are known to
cause mind wandering
analysis strongly suggested that mind
wandering was generally the cause the
cause and not merely the consequence of
unhappiness and so there are a lot of
aspects of this study that are worth
going into but the major takeaway or the
one that perhaps we should all be most
concerned with is that when we are not
focused on what we are doing we tend to
be far less happy than when we are
focused on what we were doing even if
what we're doing is something that we
don't deem very pleasant and certainly
if we are engaged in something that we
consider very pleasant and we are very
focused on well then our levels of
happiness are the highest that's sort of
obvious but what this really speaks to
is the tremendous power of building
our ability to focus on what we're doing
and to stay present to what we are doing
now this whole notion of staying present
is one that itself is a little bit
complicated and in the episode on
meditation I talked a little bit about
whether or not it's beneficial to be
present to our internal state or that is
our interceptive state you know our
feelings of our heart rate and how full
or empty our gut feels or our state of
being from our skin inward or whether or
not we should focus on being present to
things in our immediate surroundings
both our versions of being quote unquote
present as you can imagine but in the
one case we're focused internally in the
other we're focused externally and of
course most of the time it's some
combination of the two but what this
study really says is that any practice
that can powerfully impact our ability
to remain present in the activity we are
engaged in so that could even be a phone
call could be texting for that matter it
could be social media for that matter
right we're not placing judgment on the
activity here in fact what we're really
talking about is the enormous enormous
happiness increasing value of being
present to what we're doing regardless
of what we are doing and the practice
that's known to be beneficial for
increasing our ability to focus
is among other things a short meditation
practice in fact work from Winnie
Suzuki's Lab at NYU again when he's been
a guest on this podcast her laboratory
has shown that even a very brief
meditation of about 13 minutes and this
would be the sort of quote unquote
classic type of meditation of eyes
closed focusing on one's breathing even
a very brief meditation of just 13
minutes or so done consistently so
ideally every day but you have to
imagine that even if you skip a day
there are still benefits that sort of
meditation can greatly enhance one's
ability to focus in in her studies that
was also shown that sort of brief
meditation could also greatly enhance
uh mood and sleep and various aspects of
cognitive performance and work from my
laboratory in collaboration with Dr
David Spiegel at Stanford Department of
Psychiatry has shown that even briefer
meditations of even just five minutes
per day can have fairly outsized
positive effects on a number of
different parameters as well those very
brief types of meditations
because they really are focusing and
more accurately I should say refocusing
exercises when you do that sort of
activity of closing your eyes and
forcing yourself to focus and refocus on
your breath and internal state that is
directing your perception inward or if
you choose you could deliberately Focus
your perception on some external object
or sound for that matter
when one does that the circuits of the
brain involved in Focus dramatically
improve that as they rewire and
increase their ability for you to
achieve Focus
many of us have heard about meditation
many of us think about meditation as a
mindfulness exercise mindfulness in
quotes because that itself needs
definition but I prefer to view
meditations of the sort that I just
described as perceptual or Focus Based
training which is really what the data
point to you know Notions around
Consciousness and states of Mind are
very hard to Define but it's very clear
that even a five minutes a day or
ideally and up to a 13 minute a day
meditation
can greatly increase our ability to
focus and based on the findings in this
paper a Wandering mine is an unhappy
mind
also make it very clear that the ability
to refocus again and again and again
on what we're doing throughout our day
regardless of what we're doing can have
a very dramatic in fact a statistically
significant increase on our levels of
overall happiness so what else does the
research tell us we can do to increase
our levels of genuine happiness well
it's very clear based on the
longitudinal study from Harvard as well
as the Yale Happiness Project and the
work of numerous Laboratories in the U.S
and elsewhere that Quality Social
connection is extremely powerful in
terms of its ability to increase our
levels of happiness
what is Quality Social connection
Quality Social connection
falls into a number of different bins
this can be romantic connection this can
be friendship this can even be co-worker
or just daily superficial interaction
type connections that's surprising to a
lot of people because I think a lot of
people hear Quality Social connection
and they think deep conversation but
it's very clear from the research that
oftentimes our conversations with people
that we are closest to are actually
quite shallow if you think about it if
you've been in a romantic relationship
or a friendship for a long period of
time or maybe even a sibling
relationship or other family
relationship much of what you talk about
is fairly superficial or fairly trivial
in fact it's often a sharing of the
trivial day-to-day things between two
people or through groups of people that
leads to the feeling that people are
really connected to one another in
particular if it's involving shared
experiences of any kind good or bad so
there's an extensive literature on
social connection and how to build
social connection this certainly should
be the topic of a full episode of this
podcast in the not too distant future
but because social connection can have
such a powerful impact on our states of
happiness and overall well-being
I want to emphasize a few features of
social connection that I think most
people might not appreciate once again
when we hear Quality Social connection I
think most of us tend to think about
deep meaningful conversation or long
walks on the beach or camping trips
together or travel together and while
all of those certainly qualify as
wonderful opportunities for social
connection
opportunities for Quality Social
connection are certainly not limited to
those kinds of interactions in fact I
can recall
times in my graduate career so this
would be times when I was living in the
laboratory because that was a
significant portion of my graduate years
and one of the more important social
connections for me was the staff that
worked there in the wee hours of the
night and that came in very early in the
morning so one of the more regular
social connections I had is I would
brush my teeth in the hallway bathroom
and there was no one else really around
at that time except for the janitors
that tended to leave early in the
morning they had worked a good portion
of the night or that were arriving very
early in the day and the fact that I
would see them on a regular basis and
maybe exchange a few words about their
work or their families or the holidays
actually for me it became very
meaningful in part because my social
connections at the time were really
limited to only social connections that
I had in the context of work now some
people might look at my schedule at that
time and look at my life at that time
and say that was very unhealthy you know
you were lacking in certain number of
ways but frankly looking back and at the
time and I know this because I journaled
at the time I was exceedingly happy at
least for that stage of my life at that
stage of my life I wanted to be focused
primarily on doing experiments and
immersing myself in my scientific
training and for me the even seemingly
insignificant interactions of
talking to the janitor in the morning or
some of the other regular staff was not
insignificant in fact for me it was very
significant and over the holidays when
their hours were reduced I actually
missed them quite a lot and even as I
talk about this I can recall the
feelings of well-being of just seeing
familiar faces and that brings up an
important point which is
there's a quite extensive literature
pointing to the fact that when we see
faces especially faces in the morning
and in the late afternoon there is a
positive impact on the emotional
circuitry where I should say the
circuitry of the brain that underlies
emotional well-being and that shouldn't
come as surprising We As Old World
primates much like other primates are
very dependent on faces and facial
expressions in terms of registering our
own place in life and our emotional
state now the origins of this are many
in particular we have a brain area it's
actually called the fusiform face gyrus
this is an area of the brain that was
largely discovered
by a woman by Nancy kenwisher at MIT and
the can Wisher lab has done extensive
work showing that this brain area that's
dedicated to the processing of faces and
not just faces in real life but faces on
computer screens and elsewhere are
intimately tied to areas of the brain
that are associated with emotionality
that's actually work from another
laboratory to our sales laboratory at
Caltech now at UC Berkeley has shown
that this face processing area in the
brain
in both non-human primates and primates
is directly linked to the areas of our
brain that associate with anxiety and
fear but also areas of the brain that
are associated with well-being so it
comes as no surprise that when we see
faces in particular friendly faces even
if we have just brief interactions with
those faces and even if no words are
exchanged that creates the sense of
social Bond and it creates a sense of
predictability and I raise this again
because I think a lot of people think
that social connection always has to
come in the form of close friendships
which of course are wonderful or close
romantic relationships which of course
are wonderful or close family
relationships which of course are
wonderful but as we'll soon discuss in a
in our model of happiness or how to
achieve happiness based on the
scientific literature
in a few minutes
social connection can and should come in
various forms and when I say various
forms I mean forms of brief interaction
more superficial interaction and forms
of deeper interaction all of those are
relevant to our states of happiness and
there's research to support that daily
interactions with somebody at a cafe or
just a brief hello or a smile provided
that we are both present where we make
the effort to be present to those
interactions however brief they are can
have a positive effect on people's
overall well-being and not just in that
moment but consistently evidenced by the
fact I think that when I look back on
those years of working long hours in the
laboratory and essentially restricting
myself either to exercising sleeping
eating or working
again that's what I wanted at that stage
in my life certainly not the way I live
my life now but that's what I wanted
that stage of my life that even those
seemingly insignificant social
interactions were important to me and
had a potent impact on increasing my
level of happiness and frankly still do
and I feel that right now
that said I think all of us can
appreciate the immense value of social
connection that is of the more
long-lasting and for lack of a better
word richer type whether or not
that is with siblings or with parents or
with friends or with romantic partners
for that reason I want to emphasize a
little bit about what constitutes
connection and what constitutes social
connection there are basically two forms
of social connection that have been
studied and I'll review both
as it relates to increasing our levels
of happiness and the first one is
presence and eye contact and the second
is physical contact so in terms of
presence and eye contact there's been a
lot of studies about whether or not
people EX change direct eye contact
during conversation or not dictating
whether or not
each individual in that interaction
feels as if they had a connection now
again keep in mind that while we think
of connection as relating to some deep
or meaningful conversation and
oftentimes that can be the case think
for instance an excellent therapist
patient relationship or an excellent
romantic relationship or an excellent
friendship where you really feel heard
and understood or at least to the extent
that people are willing to explore
certain topics with you you're willing
to hear them and listen really carefully
for what they're saying and they're
willing to hear and listen to what
you're saying in an attempt to
understand that certainly can enhance
the sense of social connection leading
to what people would call social bonds
leading to increased happiness but eye
contact is also known to be an important
feature
the thing about eye contact is that most
people assume that a lot of eye contact
and in fact ongoing eye contact is
critical to a sense of connection and in
fact that's not the case there's a
recent paper that I find really
interesting that was published in
proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences in 2021
the title of this paper is eye contact
marks the rise and fall of shared
attention in conversation I find this
paper interesting for a number of
reasons first of all my laboratory works
on internal States and vision so it
relates directly to the work that my
laboratory does but also that it
violates what I thought was a general
rule of social connection which is this
idea that two people need to be focused
on one another that is looking at one
another directly and fairly consistently
throughout a conversation in order for
the feeling of connection to emerge but
it turns out that's not the case and in
fact just to give you the takeaway and
then I'll flesh it out a little bit with
some data
eye contact
or I should say Mutual eye contact so
two people registering the president so
the other person looking at them you're
looking at me and I'm looking at you if
you're watching this on YouTube then
perhaps we are actually doing this at
that moment and if you're listening just
know that I'm looking directly into the
camera as I'm saying this at this moment
if we were to be looking directly at one
another
that it turns out signals
The Next Step which is that it's very
likely that we will each both look away
and that turns out to be a way in which
we set and reset attention continually
during conversation so again I really
like this study because of the High
Fidelity the high temporal Precision
that is the Precision over time at which
they looked at eye contact
and engagement of attention between
individuals and they did this by looking
at things like pupil size and of course
where the eyes were looking and so on
and so forth the basic takeaway of the
study was the following here I'm quoting
from the study quote rather than
maximizing shared attention
good conversation may require shifts in
and out of shared States accompanied by
eye contact so what this basically says
is that when two people are involved in
a very let's call it an intimate
conversation but the word intimate
should not be misconstrued to mean
something about intimacy or sexual
intimacy or physical intimacy just a
conversation in which both people feel
present to the conversation and focused
on that conversation and that
conversation and its contents only the
tendency is for people to take turns
talking although sometimes depending on
the individuals they might interrupt
more or less again interrupting can be a
sign of Interest it doesn't always have
to be rude by the way but they're
sharing information
hopefully about a common topic or set of
topics they will at some moment look at
one another that's what the study shows
and that after briefly gazing directly
at one another attention Peaks and then
they will look away and attention will
get reduced and then the conversation
consists of a series of focusing back on
one another with their eyes and then
focusing off focusing on and focusing
off and those
Mutual eye contact moments actually
predict the breaking of attention so
it's this ramping up of attention and
breaking of attention ramping of
attention and breaking of attention I
think these are important results
because they violate this stereotype or
assumption that deep social connection
of the sort leading to happiness
always involves ongoing eye contact or
ongoing Focus
just as with meditation just as with any
activity frankly we undergo shifts in
attention and focus that is focus ramps
up and then it breaks and then it
re-engages it ramps up it breaks and
then it re-engages and that it turns out
is the basis of in-depth connected
conversation so for those of you that
are interested in creating social
connection
in any context
and in particular for his sake of
increasing happiness because it's very
clear that social connections even if
they are fairly superficial social
connections can increase our sense of
Happiness seeing faces is important
ideally faces in person although I
suppose these days over Zoom or over
other screen type medium would would be
a close second but the point is that if
you want to increase happiness you need
to have Quality Social connections and
if you want to have Quality Social
connections you need to be present and
engage in those social connections and
that requires a viewing of each other's
faces ideally which is not to say that a
phone call or Texas change can't be
meaningful but that faces are really the
most powerful way to engage in Social
contact and that eye contact
not consistent eye contact but eye
contact of the sort that builds up and
then breaks and builds up and breaks
across the interaction is going to be
the best way that we are aware of to
feel that one had a real connection this
should also remove any pressure that you
might feel to constantly look at
somebody or to be completely eyes open
staring at them without blinking or
diverting your attention at any point
during a conversation this also frankly
is an opportunity where if somebody says
hey you're not paying attention because
you look away that you may actually be
engaging in what is the more typical
form of healthy connection I talked
about this long ago in an episode about
focus it turns out when we are listening
very intently to somebody and trying to
remember the information they're telling
us we will often close our eyes and
that's not a form of lack of attention
that's actually a form of attending in
because we have so much of our brain
devoted to Vision 40 of our brain is
devote division in some way or another
when we close our eyes we can actually
devote more attentional resources to mem
remembering the specifics of what people
are telling us but again please don't go
through conversations with your eyes
closed the entire time I think that
would certainly not be conducive to
building social connection so we know
that faces are important for social
connection as it relates to synthetic
happiness and we know that eye contact
is really important for building social
connection
physical contact is also important for
social connection and not just romantic
or sexual type Connection in fact
there's a form of physical connection
that is present in other primates in
fact it's present as far as we know in
all mammals and is also very much a
feature of the human nervous system
and that's something called aloe
grooming I have to imagine that most
people probably haven't heard of aloe
grooming the reason I'm bringing up aloe
grooming is that it stems from a fairly
extensive literature about
the pro-social pro-happiness effects of
pets on humans in fact if you want to
read up on this there is a paper out of
Yale University on this topic that was
published in 2018 the title of the paper
is the influence of interactions with
dogs on affect AKA emotion anxiety and
arousal in children and it references
some other studies that were performed
on humans and the basic takeaway
um is that these so-called aaas animal
assisted activities
um represent a really potent way to
increase people including children's
feelings of well-being now what's
interesting about this to me is that
dogs themselves don't really have to do
much except be present in the room in
order for these positive effects that is
the reductions in anxiety increases in
happiness Etc to occur and in fact they
can be very very brief as they describe
in the paper brief unstructured
interactions with an unfamiliar dog so
you don't even need to know this dog
after exposure to a moderate stressor
showed higher positive affect relevant
participants who received a soothing
object or waited for the same amount of
time so just even seeing a dog for a
brief amount of time has been shown to
reduce stress and improve happiness or I
should say increase feelings of
happiness
overall then a child receiving a
soothing object which is at least for me
a little bit counterintuitive I would
have thought that children receiving a
soothing object would have been the more
powerful stimulus but in fact it wasn't
at least not in this study the real
question I think we should be asking
ourselves is what is it about
interactions with others and with other
animals that could potentially have this
pro-social happiness enhancing effect
and the reason I raise this is also
because I think many people
are interested in either owning or
having interactions with pets as a way
to improve their feelings of well-being
and I say having interactions with
because
I myself I'm a good example of somebody
who wasn't always able to have pets so
when I was a graduate student in a
postdoc I very much wanted a dog very
very much wanted a dog in fact there was
a rule in my family at some point that I
wasn't allowed to talk about dogs
anymore because I was talking about all
the breeds of dogs going to
dog breeders examining different breeds
going into the pound Etc the point was
that I was obsessed with getting a dog
but I knew I wasn't in a good position
to own a dog yet I didn't have the
finances I didn't have the correct
living situation
and so on eventually I did own a dog of
course but at the time I couldn't so
what I would do is every Sunday I would
go to a place where they Foster dogs and
they needed dog walkers and I would walk
their dog I would also walk
my neighbor's dogs I didn't charge them
for it in fact I felt like I was get
being paid by getting time with those
dogs and in fact I put an ad at that
time on Craigslist that I would walk
people's dogs for free and only a few
people took that seriously but of the
ones that did I had a great little Cadre
of dog owners that would allow me to
take their dogs out and I was super
happy it just made me very very happy
and I really enjoyed it
um and frankly
um it was a great opportunity for me to
also get to know the various dog breeds
and the different dog temperaments and
to learn a bit about my ability to
interact with dogs in in a certain way
actually got to be a pretty good dog
walker unfortunately later I got a
bulldog and it turns out no matter how
good a dog walker you are bulldogs just
simply don't like to walk in fact if
you've ever walked up to a bulldog and
you've offered to scratch or pet that
dog you'll notice that Bulldogs love
that and I would argue having been a
bulldog owner that they like it because
it's an opportunity for them to stop
moving but that's more about the Bulldog
than what I'm about to tell you next
which is this principle of a so-called
aloe grooming aloe grooming is a pattern
of behavior that's observed in
essentially all mammals but very
strongly in non-human primates and
primates
where
individuals within a species
touch one another and this is non-sexual
touch so this would be
um someone brushing somebody else's hair
or combing their hair or even using a
lint roller on them for instance or
someone grooming somebody else now
typically one needs to have an
established relationship with this
person so it could be a professional
type relationship where this is a barber
cutting somebody's hair or a hairdresser
cutting some or styling somebody's hair
it could be somebody giving someone a
manicure or a pedicure it could be
somebody doing skin care or massage for
somebody in a professional context or it
could be two people who have agreed that
it is appropriate for the context and
for the relationship for one person to
be grooming somebody else
can even believe it or not there's
literature on this this can even extend
into the realm of people sort of
cleaning and picking off other people
now when we see this in primates it
seems like a very cute and um sort of
almost understandable Behavior we can
see these pictures online if you look
them up you can just look up aloe
grooming and you'll see a vast number of
pictures of for instance baboons picking
little things out of each other's um
hair or um uh grooming and kind of
perusing one another to find things
presumably parasites or like little bits
of plants or something like that that
they want to remove from them aloe
grooming is known to stimulate a certain
category of neurons called the C tactile
fibers these are a particular category
of so-called Sensory neurons that
innervate our skin so these are
literally like little endings of of
neurons little wires that end up in the
skin that when they are touched lightly
tend to create a feeling of well-being
in the person that's being touched again
this is consensual touch that's very
context appropriate but it's known to
increase
levels of oxytocin a kind of hormone
slash neurotransmitter it's both really
that is known to evoke feelings of of
bond or of feeling bonded to somebody or
something and for many people we hear
about oxytocin and we think about the
bond between parent and child and
particular mother and infant where it's
been most extensively studied or between
two members of a romantic couple but if
you look at the literature on aloe
grooming what you find is that when
humans groom one another the increases
in oxytocin that are experienced are at
least on par with and in fact
more often more dramatic
in response to aloe grooming then in
response to other forms of touch so the
point here is that aloe grooming is a
pro-social behavior that tends to
associate with and promote feelings of
well-being and happiness and this is not
a trivial effect if you look at the
brain Imaging data or other forms of
data on this allo grooming is a very
powerful form of bonding between
individuals that's completely non-verbal
in fact most often it doesn't involve
eye contact I suppose two people could
be looking at one another grooming one
another but typically this is done from
the side or from behind
why did I bring up the paper on pets
well it turns out that when humans
stroke dogs or brush their dogs or
stroke cats or brush their cats Etc
that is a form of human to animal aloe
grooming and it's one in which both the
pet and the human
receive huge increases in oxytocin and
other related neurochemicals that make
us feel bonded I bring this up because
the Harvard longitudinal study on
happiness and many many others if not
hundreds of other studies on happiness
point to the importance of Quality
Social connection right you hear this
over and over again people on their
Death Beds don't say they wish they had
worked more people on their Death Beds
talk about the richness of social
connections or the wish that they had
invested more in Social connections I
think a lot of people think of social
connections only in terms of travel with
or conversation with others but much of
what we perceive as deep social
connections also involves
physical contact and that's something
that's deeper deeply rooted excuse me in
our evolutionary biology and it's
present both in us and in non-human
primates and
it's clear that we can engage in these
kinds of pro-social non-verbal non-eye
contact type behaviors through things
like non-sexual tactile touch AKA aloe
grooming so we've been talking about a
number of the different things that one
can do in order to increase levels of
happiness and certainly before we
conclude today I'm going to touch back
into not just synthetic happiness and
the various things we can do such as
pro-social spending aloe grooming social
connection
Etc but also things related to happiness
that involve
focus on vocation and work and pursuit
of goals because as I mentioned at the
beginning those are also critical to
increasing our state of happiness and
certainly our state of security and the
feeling that we can provide for
ourselves and perhaps for others as well
so we will talk about that
but I think it's also important to talk
about this notion of choice and choices
and whether or not having a lot of
freedom to choose or limited freedom in
choosing what we do and what we get and
what we are able to pursue in life how
that relates to both natural happiness
and synthetic happiness Dan Gilbert and
others have explored this issue of
freedom of choice and how it relates to
happiness
and there I must say the findings are
incredibly counter-intuitive but very
very well supported by all of their data
I'm going to summarize a large amount of
the studies at once by saying the
following Dan's laboratory and other
Laboratories have done experiments where
they give people a series of options in
one of the more classic examples they
give people the opportunity to rate a
number of different paintings or
pictures in ascending or descending
order of preference
so in other words they're deciding which
ones they like most which ones they like
least then what's interesting is the
experimenter will vary the extent to
which they have to stick to that choice
so this could be sticking to the choice
by receiving that painting to take home
or in another experiment it was having
to make a choice between giving up one
photograph that they this the research
subject took or another photograph that
they took one of the photographs was
going to go off to a publication another
one they could keep for themselves and
the conditions in that experiment were
either that you had to make the decision
and it was Final that is you could keep
one and rate your decision or you could
keep one and then you had the
opportunity to swap out that picture for
the other one at some later time in
other words these experiments really
weren't about raiding pictures they were
really about whether or not constraining
your choice meaning forcing somebody to
make a choice and stick to that choice
led to Greater levels or lesser levels
of happiness and satisfaction with that
choice and what they find consistently
is that when people have an ongoing set
of choices
it leads to reduced levels of happiness
now that might come as surprising to
many of you but I want to be clear about
what this means this is not to say that
having a lot of choices of what you like
most
leads to lesser happiness and that
having fewer choices about things you do
or objects you acquire Etc leads to
Greater happiness what this set of
experiments really points to is that
when we make a choice if we are forced
to stick to that choice We tend to be
far happier with that choice than if we
maintain the option to change our mind
the results of these experiments are
extremely informative I believe in terms
of understanding our real life happiness
that is happiness outside the laboratory
but I think they are often misunderstood
as meaning that if we have a lot of
choices we tend to be less happy than if
we have fewer choices that is not the
case having freedom of choice is
terrific and actually correlates with
elevated levels of happiness
but once we make our choice
it's clearly the case that killing all
other choices or having all other
options killed for us increases our
satisfaction with the choice that we've
made whereas leaving doors open leaving
options open greatly diminishes our
sense of satisfaction
now this has been exported to any number
of different domains so this has been
exported to the domain of making choices
about what college to go to or what
partner to select in life
in every one of those instances we see
that our happiness with our choice is
very much related to that choice being
either the only one or one of very few
other options there are a number of
different ways to interpret this through
the lens of Neuroscience we might say
that the prefrontal cortex the area of
the brain that's involved in decision
making and evaluating different options
is
an area of the brain that's vital
frankly to our Evolution as human beings
into our daily life into our whole life
it is of course the thing that allows us
to evaluate different rule sets to
change rule sets to switch contexts and
to create meaning Etc to interpret
what's good what's bad
but it's also a fairly costly process
meaning it's very metabolically
demanding and there's an entire
literature
related to what's called ego depletion
this is certainly a topic for a future
podcast but ego depletion essentially
says that if I have you attend very uh
intensely to a given task for instance
asking you to count backwards from a
thousand to zero in increments of 13 and
then have you switch about halfway
through that's hard for a lot of people
if I have you do that then your ability
to suppress impulsive behavior and to do
a hard cognitive or physical task
immediately after that is actually
suppress the so-called ego depletion it
relates to a number of different things
but it certainly relates
to engagement of the prefrontal cortex
which is very metabolically demanding so
evaluating choices and doing
computation of numbers or attending to
things with your mind and forcing
yourself to focus intensely is
metabolically demanding and that's a
limited resource that can be reset by
things like sleep and non-sleep deep
rest or idle time or letting your mind
wander in that case a positive mind
wandering to allow your brain to reset
its ability to focus but the other thing
that it does is it impacts the reward
circuitry of the brain the so-called
dopamine reward circuitry and other
reward circuitries of the brain and and
here I'm painting with a broad brush but
it essentially divides them such that
for instance if a given choice of a
let's say a partner or maybe you're
buying ourselves an article of clothing
not that I want to compare you know
selection of a life partner to selection
of an article clothing but just to give
multiple examples might give us and here
it's arbitrary units you know X
units of dopamine increase
well if we buy that article of clothing
or we select that life partner and then
we emerge from the store or the wedding
and we are focused on what we purchased
for ourselves our choice or our life
partner choice
and only that well then there's a
certain amount of neurochemical reward
associated with that and happiness and
well-being but it's also very clear that
if we
leave those choices the store or our
wedding for instance or a life with
somebody for a moment even just mentally
and start thinking about the other
options that we might entertain as
possible if those are still open to us
in reality or in our mind well then a
reward circuitry becomes fractured in a
way not physically fractured but less
attention is devoted to the reward
circuitry of associated with our choice
and as a consequence instead of it being
X units of dopamine it's X
divided by however many other choices we
might have available to us in our mind
or in reality okay so instead of and
again these are arbitrary units but
instead of a certain amount of reward
it's a certain amount of reward divided
by the number of other options that we
might be considering as alternatives to
what we chose and I think this is a very
important aspect of understanding how
limiting our choices after we've made
them is a vital part of what we call
synthetic happiness in fact we could
even go so far as to say that focusing
on the choices we've made and really
investing in those choices
as good ones were great ones and really
trying to limit our thinking to the
choices that we've made once we've made
them is perhaps also important to our
natural happiness because it's so
inextricably
entwined with what we think of as a good
life and what I mean by that is if we
are constantly in a mode of a valuative
decision making even after we've made a
decision we are not neurochemically nor
psychologically able to extract the
feelings of Happiness associated with
the choice that we made so we've talked
about a number of different dimensions
of Happiness both in synthetic and
natural happiness and some of the more
counter-intuitive aspects of happiness
for instance that people tend to adjust
their levels of happiness
not regardless but often in spite of
their life circumstances but as we
emphasized earlier in the episode that
is not to say at least the research does
not directly support the idea that a
major trauma or loss won't impact our
happiness in fact it tends to and that's
why it's important that people access
resources and work devoted to overcoming
trauma which certainly exists out there
and of course
there are the longitudinal studies and
short-term studies showing that income
level and material things don't
necessarily scale with happiness and
vice versa and yet we also acknowledge
early in the episode that while indeed
money can't buy happiness it can buffer
stress and while work doesn't
necessarily bring happiness per se work
can bring a tremendous feeling of
meaning and resources which can then put
you into context in which things like
pro-social contact and enhanced bonds
and caretaking of others and their of
you can be enhanced so it would be
unfair and in fact inaccurate to Simply
view happiness through the lens of money
doesn't matter it's all about social
connection and so on and so forth
absolutely social connections is
important which is why we spent some
minutes talking about some of the ways
to enhance social connection both with
other human beings and other animals and
them with us
I think there's a opportunity here to
take the research on happiness the
research on the Neuroscience of What
happiness and gratitude and pro-social
connection tells us and to combine it
into a bit of a a model or a toolkit if
you will and I think indeed this will be
a tool kit in one of our future toolkit
episodes likely merged with the toolkit
on gratitude which we haven't done yet
and perhaps even we will do an entire
episode on social bonds and how to
enhance or build social bonds or at
least what the science tells us about
that
if we take a step back and we look at
the concept of Happiness we can make a
couple of absolute statements that is
statements that I think very few people
if any would contest first of all
there's no single molecule or chemical
associated with happiness but that the
chemical milieu of the brain
and body is important for setting the
stage or the opportunity for happiness
hence why there are treatments aimed at
alleviating depression or Mania that
Target certain neurochemical systems and
hormone systems
happiness at least the way of I'm
framing it today has essentially two
components one is meaning that is what
sort of meaning do certain types of
interactions or behaviors could be work
could be social interactions
Etc
carry for us
and nested in that is this concept of
connection and we talked a bit about
tools for enhancing connection things
like eye contact but not constant eye
contact things like being very present
to a conversation or an activity that
you're engaging in remember we talked
about the paper a distracted mind is an
unhappy mind the paper published in
science and we talked about the study
also published in science in which
giving money
but also knowing how that money has
positively impacted others leads to this
feeling of pro-social connection and
happiness in The Giver and in the
receiver and I should mention again that
it's not just the giving of money but
also the giving of effort and time and
attention that can have similar effects
so we have meaning and connection and a
number of different ways to access those
and then we have this axis that I'm
referring to as performance and
resources and I'm talking about
performance and resources
as it relates to Natural happiness not
synthetic happiness but natural
happiness because
we would be wrong I believe if we were
to say that income doesn't matter I
think it's fair to say
based on the research that income
matters and income that can cover costs
of living plus that includes some buffer
and what do I mean by buffer I mean
buffer to the anxiety that circumstances
might change is important now that's
going to vary from person to person
meaning some people will be perfectly
happy making
one dollar more than their absolute cost
of living every month other people will
require a more substantial buffer in
order to protect them against the
negative psychological effects of
worrying about for instance inflation or
worrying that they might lose their job
and this is why I think most people
recommend having it if possible some
buffer in their bank account that could
cover
two or three or maybe even six or maybe
even 12 months of living expenses
were they to lose their job or something
catastrophic happened to them so
if we're going to talk about happiness I
think it's only fair only accurate and
frankly only respectful to talk about
living requirements and cost of living
requirements that includes this sort of
buffer and that that buffer to anxiety
is going to vary depending on how
anxious somebody gets about the
possibility of catastrophic things
happening to them like losing their job
or their rent going up or doubling and
here I'm talking about hypotheticals but
I think we all know people and perhaps
ourselves have experienced those kinds
of circumstances so when we talk about
happiness we we absolutely need to think
about resources and we also need to
think about performance I think we would
be
complete inaccurate if we simply said oh
you know any work leading to any
outcomes you know any effort regardless
of whether or not it gets you an A in
school or an F in school isn't going to
impact your happiness
I don't think anyone would agree with
that and yet if you look at the major
takeaways at least as they are
communicated
typically in the public sphere around
the longitudinal and short-term studies
of Happiness the takeaway generally is
more focused on social connection and
how money is not important I don't think
anyone that's saying that actually means
that income
that can cover your expenses plus some
buffer isn't important but it's often
not stated so if we were to come up with
a general model of happiness that
includes various tools for how to
increase our levels of happiness
I think it's only fair to include both
natural and synthetic forms of happiness
and to pursue both natural and synthetic
happiness just to remind you natural
happiness is the kind of happiness that
we associate with obtaining something
either by effort or because it was given
to us although I definitely want to
highlight the fact that receiving things
that don't require much reward in order
to receive them over time can be
detrimental to our dopamine system
that's an important aside the other form
of happiness
is the form of happiness that we call
synthetic happiness which is for
instance
focusing on social connection and we
talked about ways to do that as a means
to enhance your happiness right again
the language the the name synthetic
happiness implies something kind of
artificial but frankly genuine social
connection is genuine there's nothing
artificial about it or synthetic about
it is that you can synthesize it through
action through deliberate action
likewise being focused or encouraging
yourself working on being focused on
whatever activities you happen to be
engaged in positive or negative is known
to increase your levels of happiness
again this is a form of synthetic
happiness you're not obtaining anything
new or additional as a consequence of
this it's entirely internal right
there's no external reward there isn't
more money that arrives with this or a
better grade although I would make the
argument that if you are present to the
work you're doing in any context
physical or
mental work it's very likely that you
are going to perform better at that work
so we have natural happiness and
synthetic happiness and both of them
require our attention and effort
and in fact if we were to
draw a link between natural and
synthetic happiness it really is this
concept of presence of really being
focused on what we're doing that's most
likely to lead to the outcomes that we
want both externally in terms of
receiving monetary Rewards or grades or
praise or whatever it is that you happen
to be pursuing out there resources of
some kind and presence and striving to
be present when in the pursuit of
so-called synthetic happiness in the
form of social connection
or in the form of really focusing on the
choice that you've made and making the
best of that choice especially since you
made that choice in a way that you
deemed best at the time well that also
is known to increase
your overall levels of happiness so if
an ability to focus and attend to things
deeply is really what's most important
and really acts as the greatest lever
for both natural and synthetic happiness
well then tools like a five-minute daily
meditation or a 13 minute a day
meditation as well as tools that allow
us to get excellent sleep every night
which of course sets the basis for
attention during the day if you've ever
had a poor night's sleep then you are
very familiar with how hard it is to
focus the following day at least for
long periods of time
but building our capacity to focus
through a focusing exercise which again
is often called meditation but is really
simply just a focusing and perceptual
exercise
that's going to create an outsize effect
on all the aspects all the behaviors
that we know feed into creating natural
and synthetic happiness and so it's
really fair to say that our ability to
attend and focus really equates to
happiness so as is often typical this
podcast today we've talked a lot about
the various aspects of the science of
Happiness including the different forms
of happiness and tools to access those
different forms of Happiness if you're
learning from and or enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's a terrific zero cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on both Spotify
and apple and on both Spotify and apple
you have the opportunity to leave us up
to a five-star review if you have
questions or suggestions about topics
and guests you'd like me to include on
the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comments section on YouTube
I do read all the comments in addition
please check out the sponsors mentioned
at the beginning of today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast the huberman lab also has a zero
cost newsletter that you can access it
includes summaries of podcast episodes
as well as summaries of various
protocols for mental health physical
health and performance you can sign up
for the newsletter by going to
hubermanlab.com going to the menu and
look for the neural network newsletter
sign up you just provide your email and
I assure you we do not share your email
with anybody and again it's completely
zero cost again go to hubermanlab.com
and sign up for the neural network
newsletter and if you're not already
following us on social media we are
huberman lab on Instagram huberman lab
on Twitter and huberman lab on Facebook
and at all of those sites I provide
science and science related tools for
mental health physical health and
performance some of which overlap with
information covered on the huberman Lab
podcast but often which is distinct from
information covered on the huberman Lab
podcast so again that's huberman lab on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook once
again thank you for joining me for
today's discussion about the science of
happiness and tools for increasing your
happiness and as always thank you for
your interest in science
[Music]